Alice:杨老板你还要录一期吗
Alice: Jake, are you going to record another episode?
Jake:我不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake:看这一期怎么样
Jake: Depends on how this one goes.
Jake:对就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:你问我打算我很难回答你
Jake: It's hard to say what my plan is.
Alice:确实
Alice: True.
Lucia:你问我打算我很难回答你
Lucia: It's hard to say what my plan is.
Alice:懂了懂了
Alice: Got it, got it.
Jake:哈哈哈你问我
Jake: Hahaha, you asked me.
Jake:下一步有什么打算
Jake: What's your next plan?
Alice:来这里我突然发现我其实并不P
Alice: Coming here, I suddenly realized I'm actually not P.
Lucia:其实我也觉得
Lucia: Actually, I think so too.
Alice:其实我每天我感觉每天我都在想事情
Alice: Every day, I feel like I'm always thinking about things.
Alice:脑子里比较急
Alice: My mind is quite anxious.
Alice:呀对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Lucia:对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Alice:我 我草
Alice: I, I, damn.
Jake:哎哟哟
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Lucia:我太重了
Lucia: I'm too heavy.
Alice:没事它这个石子不是那啥 的
Alice: It's okay, this stone is not really...
Jake:没事没事没有对对对石子
Jake: It's okay, it's okay, yeah, the stone.
Jake:石头的问题
Jake: It's the stone's problem.
Jake:不是您的不是您的问题
Jake: It's not your fault, not your fault.
Lucia:换个凳子
Lucia: Let's change the stool.
Alice:这晚上坐着还有点冰屁股呢
Alice: Sitting here at night, my butt is a bit cold.
Lucia:是晚上还挺冷的
Lucia: Yeah, it's quite cold at night.
Jake:晚上挺冷的 这几天
Jake: It's pretty cold at night these days.
Lucia:我都
Lucia: I've been...
Jake:这一周竟然都没有下雨
Jake: It hasn't rained at all this week.
Jake:有点意思
Jake: Interesting.
Alice:挺好
Alice: Pretty good.
Jake:北京是这样吗
Jake: Is it like this in Beijing?
Alice:北京下雨本来就不不多
Alice: It doesn't rain much in Beijing anyway.
Lucia:不太多
Lucia: Not much.
Jake:噢 噢  噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Alice:嗯但是这几天天气都很好
Alice: But the weather has been really nice these days.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Alice:对空气还很好
Alice: And the air is pretty good.
Lucia:所以其实
Lucia: So actually...
Alice:这就不太
Alice: It's not really...
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:假北京
Jake: Fake Beijing.
Lucia:所以我们其实应该多录点户外的
Lucia: So we should actually film more outdoors.
Alice:户外也差不多可以了
Alice: Yeah, outdoors should be good enough.
Lucia:趁着天气好
Lucia: While the weather is nice.
Jake:对已经加了好几场了 以前很少
Jake:主要是我不想跑
Jake: Mainly, I just don't want to run.
Lucia:加了好几场去超市的吧
Lucia: Added several trips to the supermarket, right?
Jake:对还有别的户外
Jake: Yes, and other outdoor activities.
Jake:确实没有
Jake: Indeed, there's none.
Jake:那那打的就是抓娃娃
Jake: The game is about catching dolls.
Jake:那确实很突然
Alice:啊是
Alice: Ah, yes.
Lucia:所以像抓娃娃那种说介绍有什么用啊
Lucia: So, what's the point of introducing something like catching dolls?
Katrina: 好奇
Katrina: Curious.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia:呃我又不在你们竞争对手公司是吧
Lucia: Uh, I’m not with your competitor, right?
Lucia:可以放心的给我透露一点
Lucia: You can trust me with a little info.
Jake:没关系这东西都开源了
Jake: It's okay, this stuff is all open source.
Jake:过两个月啥也没
Jake: In a couple of months, it’ll be nothing.
Jake:对嗯我不知道
Jake: Yes, um, I don't know.
Jake:不是不是我大概知道
Jake: No, no, I sort of know.
Jake:是说里边他们会抓一个娃娃对吧
Jake: They usually catch a doll inside, right?
Jake:最后他不是以前不是抓那个娃娃吗
Jake: Before, they used to catch that doll, right?
Jake:然后那个娃娃可能就能在某一个时间
Jake: And then that doll might be at a certain time.
Jake:有一个年纪
Jake: At a certain age.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:是娃娃岛来的呀
Jake: It’s from Doll Island.
Jake:然后就可以倒到那个时间点去
Jake: Then you can go back to that point in time.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia:那如果没抓上呢
Lucia: What if you don't catch it?
Jake:没抓上没抓上我就会有别的解释
Jake: If you don't catch it, I'll have another explanation.
Alice:比如说
Alice: For example?
Jake:不知道啊现在不是我不知道
Jake: I don't know, I really don't know.
Alice:哎呦我的天呐
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Lucia:好有意思啊
Lucia: That's so interesting.
Lucia:这是这是正常的么
Lucia: Is this, is this normal?
Jake:总会
Jake: Always.
Lucia:这真是
Lucia: This is really...
Lucia:这是应该的
Lucia: This should be.
Alice:这是这是可以的
Alice: This is, this is possible.
Alice:这竟然是可以的
Alice: This is actually possible.
Shure: 来咱们下去把那个香槟开一下
Shure: Come on, let’s go downstairs and pop the champagne.
Alice:给了一个很真诚但是感觉不太真诚回答
Alice: That was a sincere yet not so sincere answer.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia:他经常说出一些
Lucia: He often says some...
Lucia:我觉得好像是在忽悠我们
Lucia: I feel like he's just trying to fool us.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But this time, he's telling the truth.
Alice:但是这才是真的话
Alice: But this time, he's telling the truth.
Lucia:我觉得你才应该去玩那个四真两假
Lucia: I think you should play that "two truths and a lie" game.
Lucia:那个
Lucia: That one.
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Jake:噢 噢
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia:你就光把你记好的那个大家觉得肯定是编的
Lucia: Just remember the one that everyone thinks is definitely made up.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:p到如此地步
Alice: To such an extent.
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
Lucia:这是可以的吗
Lucia: Is this okay?
Alice:我现在就改换人格
Alice: I'm changing my personality right now.
Jake:做科研嘛
Jake: Doing research.
Jake:就是要探索
Jake: It's all about exploring.
Alice:哈哈我现在就改换人格了
Alice: Haha, I'm changing my personality right now.
Alice:脱下我的ENMP面具
Alice: Taking off my ENMP mask.
Jake:你们J很多啊
Jake: You have a lot of J's.
Jake:你们这些J人
Jake: You J people.
Lucia:我真的是偏远
Lucia: I'm really remote.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:不知为何我总觉得哪里有点怪怪的
Lucia: For some reason, I always feel something's a bit off.
Lucia:我们不会真的在传销组织吧
Lucia: Are we really in a pyramid scheme?
Alice:这是啥呀 刘婷
Alice: What's this, Liu Ting?
Alice:又是 哦 葱
Alice: Again... oh, scallions.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Alice:我今天吃的时候甚至都没吃葱
Alice: I didn't even eat scallions when I ate today.
Lucia:不是干吃吗
Lucia: Isn't it just eating dry?
Shure: 哎哎别别别
Shure: Hey, hey, no, no, no.
Alice:比萨整成了中西合壁了
Alice: Pizza has become a fusion of East and West.
Lucia:所以被吃掉的那些东西他也可以
Lucia: So, the things that were eaten, he can also...
Jake:对吃掉的这些东西
Jake: Yes, the things that were eaten.
Jake:他也可以 他也可以 怎么
Jake: He can, he can, how...
Jake:可以和
Jake: Can...
Lucia:它就跟娃娃机一个道理吗
Lucia: It's just like those claw machines.
Jake:吃掉的这些东西
Jake: The things that were eaten.
Jake:这也不是
Jake: This isn't...
Jake:就是这些
Jake: Just these...
Jake:可能吃披萨这种活动呢
Jake: Maybe activities like eating pizza...
Jake:刚刚我们也没怎么好好录
Jake: We didn't really record that well just now.
Jake:但是就是说是前一段和后一段
Jake: But, you know, it's like the beginning and the end.
Jake:中间有个尬舞
Jake: There's an awkward dance in the middle.
Jake:然后但是
Jake: And, but...
Jake:你们可能就是我们现在录的这些东西
Jake: You guys might be wondering about the stuff we're recording now.
Jake:然后就就有一个问
Jake: So, there's a question.
Jake:就是
Jake: It's like...
Jake:就问AI说我们刚刚可能干一些什么事情
Jake: Ask the AI what we might have been doing just now.
Jake:在一个空余的时间里面
Jake: During some free time.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:那最后我们那个每个人的行动路线
Alice: So, in the end, everyone's action routes.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:会会显示每个人偏好干嘛
Alice: Will show what everyone prefers to do.
Jake:这个应该很容易
Jake: That should be easy.
Alice:我偏好洗衣服
Alice: I prefer doing laundry.
Alice:哈哈哈我每天都把油弄在衣服上
Alice: Hahaha, I always get oil on my clothes every day.
Jake:对 你如果
Jake: Yeah, if you...
Alice:每天都在洗衣服
Alice: I'm doing laundry every day.
Jake:对你带着眼镜一直洗衣服啊
Jake: Yeah, you keep doing laundry with your glasses on.
Jake:确实知道你是洗衣服干啥
Jake: We definitely know you're doing laundry.
Alice:对然后我一直在擦擦桌子
Alice: Yeah, and I'm always wiping the table.
Lucia:哦靠
Lucia: Oh, damn.
Jake:啊 这个没问题 对
Jake: Ah, no problem. Yeah.
Lucia:主要是研究者不好研究我这些
Lucia: Mainly, researchers have a hard time studying my stuff.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Jake:啥啥啥
Jake: What? What?
Lucia:主要是研究者不知道这个人是我就行
Lucia: The main thing is researchers don't know it's me, that's all.
Jake:OKOK
Jake: OK, OK.
Alice:我无所谓
Alice: I don't care.
Alice:那那是不是我们就要那个
Alice: So, does that mean we have to...
Lucia:要不然它就会发现我经常在摸鱼
Lucia: Otherwise, they'll find out I'm slacking off all the time.
Jake:那这个太常见了
Jake: That's too common.
Jake:哈哈哈这是人类本质
Jake: Hahaha, that's human nature.
Alice:那我们这个什么
Alice: So, what about our...
Lucia:人类的本质是摸鱼 好 不是
Lucia: Human nature is slacking off. Okay, no...
Alice:你说啥来着
Alice: What were you saying?
Alice:坏了 找不着了
Alice: Oh no, I can't find it.
Alice:真找不着了
Alice: Really can't find it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Alice:忘了说一半忘了
Alice: Forgot, halfway through I forgot.
Alice:难受啊我现在很难受
Alice: Ugh, I feel awful, I feel really awful right now.
Lucia:没事 你学学领导
Lucia: It's okay, just follow the leader.
Jake:想一想想一想想一想
Jake: Think about it, think about it, think about it.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:不想了吧
Jake: Let's not think about it.
Shure: 来快快快
Shure: Come on, come on, come on.
Lucia:你看
Lucia: Look.
Shure: 下来下来下来
Shure: Get down, get down, get down.
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:过两分钟就想起来了
Jake: You'll remember in a couple of minutes.
Lucia:要是过两分钟也想不起来那就
Lucia: What if you still can't remember after two minutes?
Jake:那就忘掉
Jake: Then just forget about it.
Alice:啊对对对别别别
Alice: Oh, right, right, right, no, no, no.
Alice:就是我们这个
Alice: It's just that our...
Alice:最后那个每个人的数据还会让自己看
Alice: In the end, everyone will get to see their own data.
Alice:就是需要什么删什么或者之类的
Alice: You can delete whatever you need or something like that.
Jake:对我们会帮你们先删
Jake: Yes, we'll help you delete it first.
Jake:我回头给你们
Jake: I'll give it to you later.
Lucia:领导你没给我看就是到达的视频
Lucia: Leader, you didn't show me the arrival video.
Lucia:你忘记了
Lucia: You forgot.
Jake:啊就今天的这个
Jake: Oh, today's one.
Alice:我是不是没有到达的视频
Alice: Do I have no arrival video?
Lucia:太P了嗯
Lucia: It's too fake, hmm.
Jake:就是到达的视频
Jake: It's the arrival video.
Jake:就是今天放的那个
Jake: The one we played today.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:我我是不是没有到达
Alice: Do I... do I not have an arrival video?
Lucia:太P了
Lucia: It's too fake.
Lucia:但是这才是真的话
Lucia: But this is the truth.
Jake:你没有到达的视频
Jake: You don't have an arrival video.
Jake:因为他们没有录
Jake: Because they didn't record it.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Lucia:一般如果有志愿者去接你的话就有
Lucia: Usually, if a volunteer goes to pick you up, there is a video.
Shure: 该把这也开了吧
Shure: Should we turn this on too?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:有但但没有录
Alice: There is, but it wasn't recorded.
Jake:开开开开
Jake: Turn it on, turn it on, turn it on.
Alice:我以为录了无所谓
Alice: I thought it was recorded, doesn't matter.
Shure: 我把他们都叫下来
Shure: I'll call them all down.
Shure: 然后咱开一个
Shure: Then we'll start one.
Jake:哎好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Alice:来听响了
Alice: Come and listen.
Shure: ego life圆满收官
Shure: Ego life wraps up perfectly.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:明天打扫卫生
Alice: Clean up tomorrow.
Shure: 快快快快下来下来下来下来来
Shure: Quick, quick, quick, come down, come down, come down.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Clean up the end.
Alice:这粉底都擦掉了
Alice: The foundation is all rubbed off.
Lucia:一般在我们宿舍
Lucia: Usually in our dorm.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声的意思是
Lucia: Cleaning up the end means.
Lucia:这剩一块披萨的感觉
Lucia: It feels like there's one piece of pizza left.
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声
Lucia: Clean up the end.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:那他压力挺大的
Jake: That sounds stressful.
Alice:受不了 刘婷 解决一下
Alice: Can't take it, Ting Liu, handle it.
刘婷:干啥
Ting Liu: What?
Lucia:收拾收拾尾声哈哈哈
Lucia: Clean up the end, hahaha.
Jake:所以今天的那个视频要调点角度
Jake: So, today's video, do we need to adjust the angle?
Jake:还是什么
Jake: Or what?
Lucia:我还没看呢
Lucia: I haven't watched it yet.
Jake:你还没看到呢
Jake: You haven't seen it yet.
Alice:嗯没关系大家已经看了
Alice: Hmm, it's okay, everyone has seen it.
Lucia:嗯 你没放
Lucia: Hmm, you didn't put it up.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:放话太早了是吧
Jake: Put it up too early, right?
Lucia:对放的是我还在
Lucia: Yeah, I was still.
Lucia:我咱俩是不是都没看
Lucia: Weren't we both not watching?
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia:咱俩在下面我记得
Lucia: We were downstairs, I remember.
Alice:对我没有看到
Alice: Yeah, I didn't see it.
Jake:行
Jake: Okay.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Jake:拿出来看看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Shure的女友:没有我说接孩子放学啊
Shure's GF: No, I said pick up the kids after school.
Jake:共赏佳叫什么
Jake: Enjoy the beauty of what?
Jake:纪录片啊
Jake: A documentary, right?
Jake:耶 到点了
Jake: Yay, time's up.
Jake:到钟了
Jake: The clock's up.
男嘉宾:你觉得
Male Guest: Do you think
男嘉宾:你觉得今天下午可以邀请来那个
Male Guest: Do you think we can invite him this afternoon?
Shure: 不用不用不用
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 来 杨老板 没你不行
Shure: Come on, Jake, we can't do it without you.
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:啊 哦 哦哦
Jake: Ah, oh, okay.
Jake:行行行
Jake: Alright, alright.
Shure: 把这开完
Shure: Let's finish this.
男嘉宾:看到没有牛逼看到没有
Male Guest: See that? Awesome, right?
男嘉宾:他在清华跟我们来的距离是一样的
Male Guest: The distance from Tsinghua to us is the same.
Nicous: 太远了 我草
Nicous: So far, damn.
男嘉宾:哈哈哈巨远
Male Guest: Hahaha, super far.
Katrina: 有点想死
Katrina: I feel like dying.
Nicous: 采访一下
Nicous: Let's interview.
Nicous: 你觉得那个男生喜欢他吗
Nicous: Do you think that guy likes her?
Jack: 婧康有女朋友他应该能感受出来
Jack: Jingkang has a girlfriend, he should know.
女嘉宾:谁有女朋友啊
Female Guest: Who has a girlfriend?
女嘉宾:你有女朋友啊
Female Guest: You have a girlfriend?
Jake:以前有过
Jake: Used to.
Jake:以前有现在没有
Jake: Used to, not now.
Nicous: 不好意思哎我不是故意的
Nicous: Sorry, I didn't mean it.
Shure: 哈哈哈 来来来
Shure: Hahaha, come on.
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Nicous: 完了我靠完了
Nicous: It's over, damn it.
Shure: 康康先生咱们先把香槟开了
Shure: Mr. Kangkang, let's open the champagne first.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Damn, damn.
Nicous: 完了卧槽
Nicous: It's over, damn.
Tasha:提起了人家的伤心史
Tasha: You've brought up a painful memory.
Jack: 节约人品你同等开一个是一个
Jack: Save your luck, use it wisely.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Damn, damn.
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I, I think
Jake:得也有 哈哈哈
Jake: there's also... Hahaha.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 一起一起来
Shure: All together now.
Lucia:所以你是他的老公吗
Lucia: So are you his husband?
Alice:不是不是不是
Alice: No, no, no.
Shure: come om
Shure: Come on.
Lucia:我开玩笑的啦
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Shure: 小心崩到你的电脑哦
Shure: Be careful not to hit your computer.
Jake: 好嘞 我们先开香槟
Jake: Alright, let's open the champagne first.
Alice:让我来录一下
Alice: Let me record it.
Lucia:我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm joking.
Lucia:开玩笑的
Lucia: Just kidding.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:321 哎
Alice: 3, 2, 1, hey!
Alice:让大家都出来
Alice: Everyone, come out.
Jake:不理你
Jake: Ignoring you.
Shure: 他是不是偷偷说我坏话呢
Shure: Is he secretly talking bad about me?
Jake:手舞足蹈说你坏话
Jake: He's bad-mouthing you with gestures.
Shure的女友:某种意义上
Shure's GF: In a way.
Shure的女友:其实我不太在意你们两个人什么关系
Shure's GF: Actually, I don't really care about your relationship.
Shure的女友:啊但是他的视线就是占比
Shure's GF: Ah, but his gaze is mostly on you.
Shure的女友:大概是
Shure's GF: Probably because...
Shure: 直接开始就行
Shure: Just start directly.
Shure的女友:往往往然后往大家那里视线扫两眼
Shure's GF: He glances at everyone, then the rest of the time he's looking at you.
Shure的女友:然后剩下的时间都在你这
Shure's GF: Then the rest of the time he's looking at you.
Jack: 这可是非常骗不了人的
Jack: This is something you can't fake.
Katrina: 啊真的吗
Katrina: Oh really?
Shure: 就应该把这个眼球追踪都给他追踪到
Shure: We should track his eye movements.
Alice:全都有这个香肠
Alice: Everyone has this sausage.
Tasha:要脱单了吗
Tasha: About to find love?
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know, right?
Nicous: 哎 对对追踪一下对
Nicous: Yeah, yeah, track it.
Katrina: 我只觉得有点奇怪的是
Katrina: What I find strange is...
Katrina: 他为啥老让他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: Why does he always want to take pictures of us together?
Katrina: 他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: He takes pictures of us.
Katrina: 明明我们一直在拍情侣
Katrina: Even though we're always taking couple photos.
Katrina: 他非要就一直跟我俩拍照
Katrina: He insists on taking pictures with us.
Nicous: 好 孺子不可教也
Nicous: Alright, this kid is hopeless.
Shure: 不不不咱咱先把香槟开了回
Shure: No, no, let's just open the champagne first.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Nicous: 其实我觉得你邀请他过来就是那意思
Nicous: Actually, I think you invited him for that reason.
Nicous: 因为你俩
Nicous: Because you two...
Jack: 就你邀请的人家
Jack: The one you invited.
Jack: 难道不是
Jack: Isn't it?
Nicous: 就是
Nicous: That's right
Katrina: 我看过很多玩的很好的男生朋友
Katrina: I've seen many guy friends who are really good at playing
Katrina: 很好的男生朋友
Katrina: Really good guy friends
Katrina: 我摇一个怎么讲
Katrina: I mean, how should I say this
Katrina: 就是因为他在场内啊
Katrina: It's because he's in the arena
Shure: 因为他在北京
Shure: Because he's in Beijing
Nicous: 不 在他就觉得
Nicous: No, he just thinks
Nicous: 昂勒密
Nicous: On the inside
Katrina: 为什么不能邀请好朋友
Katrina: Why can't you invite good friends
Nicous: 昂勒密
Nicous: On the inside
Shure: 不 我们我们先开
Shure: No, we should start first
Shure: 开了他边喝边聊行不行
Shure: Start it and he can drink and chat along, okay?
Jake:走走走边喝
Jake: Let's go, let's drink and chat
Jake:边喝边聊
Jake: Drink and chat
Nicous: 听我说你
Nicous: Listen to me
Nicous: 有人说是这样的
Nicous: Someone said this
Jake:边喝边聊边喝走走走
Jake: Drink and chat, drink, let's go
Shure: 哎呀哎呀 边喝边
Shure: Oh, oh, drink and
Shure: 他他这个他这个
Shure: He, he, this guy
Shure: 葡萄倒了快他妈1,000下了已经
Shure: The grape has been poured almost a thousand times already
Nicous: 哎听我说这样的
Nicous: Hey, listen to me, it's like this
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Jake:在进行
Jake: Proceeding
Jack: 有没有一种可能敬请期待
Jack: Is there a possibility to stay tuned
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Ouch
Jack: 这个这个事情很显然啊
Jack: This, this is very obvious
Jack: 这个事就是很
Jack: This thing is just very
男嘉宾:就是现在那个男生一定觉得
Male Guest: Right now that guy must be thinking
Nicous: 如果你后面还跟他去正常联系
Nicous: If you keep in regular contact with him later
Nicous: 他就会觉得这个人怎么一直吊着
Nicous: He will think why is this person always leading him on
Nicous: 有没有一种可能
Nicous: Is there a possibility
Nicous: 你觉得那些好兄弟都不喜欢你
Nicous: You think those good brothers don't like you
Nicous: 所以你觉得无所谓
Nicous: So you don't care
Jack: 对啊或他们就他们觉得对啊但是
Jack: Yeah, or they just think yeah but
Nicous: 正好这个男的喜欢就一样了
Nicous: Just so happens this guy likes you the same way
Katrina: 所以他觉得在他的视角
Katrina: So from his perspective
Katrina: 我邀请他就代表我喜欢他
Katrina: Inviting him means I like him
Nicous: 对而且而且
Nicous: Yes, and also
Nicous: 重点问题是我今天下午才坐到你旁边
Nicous: The main issue is that I only sat next to you this afternoon.
Lucia:什么逻辑
Lucia: What kind of logic is that?
Nicous: 你们俩就那样
Nicous: You two were just like that.
Nicous: 硬坐了一下午
Nicous: Sat there all afternoon.
Nicous: 对啊哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, haha.
Katrina: 他都坐过来了我能跑吗
Katrina: He already sat down, could I just run away?
Nicous: 那你应该喊那你应该喊一个董超超
Nicous: Then you should've called Jack.
Jack: 你没看我当时不往那坐吗
Jack: Didn't you see I wasn't sitting there?
Katrina: 坐我俩中间吗
Katrina: Sit between us?
Jack: 我当时都走了呀
Jack: I was already leaving.
Jack: 我本来坐在这
Jack: I was sitting here originally.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 你怎么一言不发就开呢
Katrina: Why did you start without saying a word?
Katrina: 就开呢还没录呢
Katrina: You started without recording.
Nicous: 对啊
Nicous: Yeah.
男嘉宾:我给你塞回去
Male Guest: I'll put it back.
男嘉宾:你重新再开一遍
Male Guest: You start it again.
Jack: 你再开一回吧
Jack: Start it again.
Shure: 我真
Shure: I really...
Jack: 没摇吧
Jack: Didn't shake it, right?
Lucia:塞回去气不够了
Lucia: Put it back, the air isn't enough.
Shure: 我摇了我真摇了
Shure: I shook it, I really did.
Jack: 多摇点再来一回再
Jack: Shake it more and try again.
Shure: 在
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 再来一条
Shure: Let's do it again.
Shure: 这玩意怎么塞回去啊 哥
Shure: How do you put this thing back, bro?
Jake:他 他是
Jake: He, he is...
Jake:他是谁啊
Jake: Who is he?
男嘉宾:哎是那天这个还有个塞
Male Guest: Oh, it's that day, there was still a...
Jake:哎呀 我草
Jake: Oh my god.
Shure: 我把还有几个
Shure: I still have a few.
Katrina: 就是男女对唱
Katrina: It's a duet.
Katrina: 他非要我看他的眼睛
Katrina: He insisted I look into his eyes.
Katrina: 这是什么意思啊
Katrina: What does that even mean?
男嘉宾:那个有可能真只是有病我跟你讲
Male Guest: He might really just be sick, I'm telling you.
男嘉宾:因为如果因为如果他真的很
Male Guest: Because if, because if he really...
男嘉宾:哈哈哈我要飞起一花草呢
Male Guest: Haha, I could just fly up with a flower.
男嘉宾:我们一下子下决定
Male Guest: Let's just decide quickly.
男嘉宾:只要这个男人刚刚结束一下午
Male Guest: As long as this man just finished a whole afternoon.
男嘉宾:对你刚才说这个表现你让我听见
Male Guest: About what you just said, let me hear it.
男嘉宾:我觉得是有病的
Male Guest: I think he's sick.
男嘉宾:但今天这个男生就是这个关系
Male Guest: But today, this guy is just like that.
Katrina: 有时候我也觉得他有病
Katrina: Sometimes I also think he's sick.
男嘉宾:但今天这个男生不是
Male Guest: But today, this guy isn't.
Katrina: 我跟很多男生关系都好
Katrina: I have good relationships with many guys.
Katrina: 都是哥们对
Katrina: They're all my buddies, right?
男嘉宾:那他
Male Guest: Then he...
男嘉宾:那他可能就是真把你当哥们对唱
Male Guest: Then he probably really sees you as just a buddy.
男嘉宾:那就是真哥们对
Male Guest: Then he's a true buddy.
Shure: 可以用纸杯了吗
Shure: Can we use the paper cups now?
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jack: 走掉了
Jack: He left.
Shure的女友:他真的有
Shure's GF: He really has...
Shure的女友:就是他整个人注意力都在
Shure's GF: His entire attention is just on...
Nicous: 不是你哦
Nicous: It's not you.
Jack: 就是这个点
Jack: It's just this point.
Nicous: 你找男生
Nicous: You find a guy...
Katrina: 他没有普通朋友
Katrina: He doesn't have ordinary friends.
Shure的女友:就那天
Shure's GF: Just that day...
Nicous: 没出的问题
Nicous: No problems appeared.
Nicous: 是他出问题
Nicous: He's the problem.
Lucia:咱们不是在这外边耍
Lucia: We're not just messing around out here.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: ego life
Jake:哎大卖大卖
Jake: Hey, big sales, big sales.
Shure: 大卖了
Shure: Big sales.
Shure: 圆满结束了
Shure: It ended perfectly.
Shure: 基本上
Shure: Basically.
Nicous: 解说是
Nicous: The commentary is...
Lucia: 谁要开车
Lucia: Who's driving?
Lucia:你要开车啊
Lucia: Are you driving?
Jake:那你喝点橙汁吧
Jake: Then you should have some orange juice.
女嘉宾:可惜了啊
Female Guest: What a pity.
Jake:要不
Jake: Or else...
Nicous: 没事没事
Nicous: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:可惜了了
Lucia: What a pity.
Nicous: 我不喝
Nicous: I won't drink.
Alice:啊来吧
Alice: Oh, come on.
Jake:你喝点桃汁吧
Jake: How about some peach juice?
Jake:白水啊
Jake: Plain water, huh?
Alice:破 破戒了
Alice: Broke the rules.
Lucia:农夫微醺水
Lucia: Farmer's Lightly Intoxicated Water.
Jake:哈哈哈可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Shure: 来点吧路亚
Shure: Have a little, Lure.
Jake:少喝点啊
Jake: Drink less, okay?
Shure的女友:就你这张脸你可以觉得所有就是
Shure's GF: With your face, you can think everyone is...
Shure的女友:你觉得啊这个人好像对我有意思
Shure's GF: You think, oh, this person seems to like me.
Shure的女友:那种男生你都可以归为
Shure's GF: You can categorize those kinds of guys as...
Nicous: 喝出了粮食酒的感觉
Nicous: Feels like drinking grain alcohol.
Alice:才十来度
Alice: It's just about ten degrees.
Jake:来来敬敬敬
Jake: Come on, cheers, cheers.
Jake:你的好朋友来
Jake: Your good friend is here.
男嘉宾:一点酒不喝吗
Male Guest: Not drinking any alcohol?
Nicous: 我不要
Nicous: I don't want to.
男嘉宾:哦晚上开车是吧
Male Guest: Oh, driving tonight?
男嘉宾:一点车不开就可以
Male Guest: If you don't drive, you can.
Lucia:一点车不开
Lucia: Not driving at all.
Shure: OK都有了吧
Shure: OK, got everything?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 你你你来一杯吗
Shure: You, you, want a drink?
Shure的女友:从你有感觉的那一刻起
Shure's GF: From the moment you felt something...
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 我们举杯敬
Shure: Let's toast.
Shure: 敬ego来来先先敬ego life一杯
Shure: Cheers to ego, come on, cheers to ego life first.
Shure: 然后再再说这个来
Shure: Then we'll talk about this, come on.
Shure: 哈哈哈来来来ego life哎
Shure: Hahaha, come on, come on, ego life, hey.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
男嘉宾: 好
Male Guest: Good.
刘婷:没事还会有还会有
Liu Ting: It's okay, there will be more chances.
Shure: 谁问的倒吗
Shure: Who asked to pour it out?
Lucia:还有还有
Lucia: There's more, there's more.
Lucia:没倒完呢
Lucia: Not finished pouring yet.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:说到哪了
Jake: What were we talking about?
Katrina: 我我真的很想知道
Katrina: I really want to know.
Katrina: 那他11月份的时候跟我分开
Katrina: When he broke up with me in November...
Katrina: 分开就这样拥抱一下
Katrina: We just hugged like this.
Katrina: 我以为是礼节
Katrina: I thought it was a formality.
Katrina: 就是有一种意思
Katrina: It's like there's a meaning to it.
Nicous: 谁跟暧昧拥抱一下
Nicous: Who's being ambiguous and hugging?
Nicous: 不会的不会的
Nicous: No way, no way.
Nicous: 绝对不会
Nicous: Definitely not.
Jack: 这国内啊哪来那么多那种
Jack: In our country, where do you find so many of those?
Katrina: 没有就是就是
Katrina: No, it's just, just...
Katrina: 我感觉这张脸不是啊
Katrina: I feel like this face isn't it.
Jack: 这国内啊
Jack: In our country...
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure的女友:能完成你觉得所有的男生对你啊
Shure's GF: Can you finish, do you think all guys are like that to you?
Shure的女友:你觉得OK
Shure's GF: You think it's okay.
Shure的女友:他可能有点暧昧
Shure's GF: He might be a bit ambiguous.
Shure的女友:你就可以把他归到啊
Shure's GF: You can categorize him as...
Shure的女友:他喜欢我这个范围内
Shure's GF: He likes me, within this range.
Shure的女友:因为
Shure's GF: Because...
Jack: 你这还明显
Jack: You're being obvious.
Lucia:然后我帮你们都打一下
Lucia: And then I'll help you all mark it.
Jack: 分开的时候拥抱一下
Jack: Hug when you part.
Jack: 生病的时候给你买药
Jack: Buy medicine when you're sick.
Jack: 今天过去坐你旁边啊
Jack: Today sit next to you, right?
Jack: 今天今天就是今天
Jack: Today, just today.
Jack: 这一天你生病了还给你买药
Jack: On this day you're sick, still buy you medicine.
Katrina: 他坐我旁边
Katrina: He sits next to me.
Katrina: 好奇怪我都我一个人坐在那
Katrina: So weird, I'm sitting there alone.
Lucia:别人应该也也也吃不完
Lucia: Others probably can't finish it either.
Katrina: 他非要从凳子上坐过来
Katrina: He insists on sitting over from the bench.
Jack: 生病给你买药还不奇怪吗
Jack: Buying medicine when you're sick isn't weird?
女嘉宾:盖死都怪怪
Female Guest: It's weird no matter what.
Shure的女友:这还不能说明问题吗
Shure's GF: Doesn't this indicate something?
Jack: 对啊盖死的全在凳子上
Jack: Yeah, totally weird on the bench.
Shure: 我天啊 你的
Shure: Oh my God, your...
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  AI能分析明白这个吗
Shure: Can AI understand this?
Jake: 我觉得能
Jake: I think it can.
Jake:我觉得AI已经能分析明白
Jake: I think AI can already understand this.
Shure: AI能分清明白你这个是吗
Shure: Can AI distinguish this?
Jake:您这得 它得他得训练训练你
Jake: It has to, it has to be trained, trained by you.
Jack: 我感觉我们几个毛都已经能推测出来
Jack: I feel like we can already predict this.
Jake:他得训一训的得训一训
Jake: It needs to be trained, needs to be trained.
Jack: 到时候我们给它
Jack: We'll give it to it then.
男嘉宾:从这两个人是什么关系
Male Guest: What's the relationship between these two people?
男嘉宾:从他的描述来看
Male Guest: Based on his description,
男嘉宾:这两个人很有可能是情侣关系
Male Guest: it seems like they might be a couple.
Jack: 嗯对
Jack: Yeah, right.
Jack: 要给派的DVT
Jack: Gotta give the DVT to Pi.
Jack: 估计能行啊
Jack: I think it'll work out.
Jack: 我我我们来看
Jack: Let's check it out.
Jack: 说到照片
Jack: Speaking of photos,
Jack: 这不有吗
Jack: isn't there one here?
Jack: 让让大家来介绍一下
Jack: Let's have everyone introduce it.
男嘉宾:来来来搞个
Male Guest: Come on, let's do it.
Jake:唉
Jake: Hey.
Jack: 来大家来照照照片
Jack: Come on, everyone, let's take a look.
Shure: 还要吗
Shure: Do we still need it?
Jack: 哇拍这么多呀拍这么多拍这么多
Jack: Wow, so many photos, so many photos.
Nicous: 拍这么多可以啊
Nicous: Taking so many is okay.
Katrina: 他让他拍的呀
Katrina: He asked him to take them.
Jack: 我靠他们给他拍太爽了
Jack: Damn, they took too many for him.
Jake:那确实不用看了
Jake: No need to look anymore.
Jake:你用文心
Jake: Use Wenxin.
Nicous: 三三个选项情侣陌生人啊
Nicous: Three options: couple, strangers.
Nicous: 4个女喜欢男的
Nicous: Four: she likes him.
Nicous: 男喜欢女的
Nicous: He likes her.
Jake:哎我看一下啊
Jake: Let me see.
Nicous: 那还是4个
Nicous: So it's still four.
男嘉宾:这个我感觉
Male Guest: I feel like,
男嘉宾:我感觉女喜欢男和男喜欢女
Male Guest: I feel like she likes him and he likes her.
男嘉宾:PPT看不出来
Male Guest: Can't tell from the PPT.
Katrina: 这没什么呀
Katrina: It's nothing.
Katrina: 就两个人拍一张照片
Katrina: Just two people taking a photo.
Jack: 我来看看我来看看
Jack: Let me see, let me see.
Jake:这一张好像还
Jake: This one looks okay.
Katrina: 因为当时会觉得他是一个比较
Katrina: Because at the time, you'd think he was quite...
Jake:你要你要
Jake: You want, you want...
Katrina: 唯一的人觉得我俩见一面不容易Katrina: 就想拍照我就这样想
Katrina: The only person who thought it was hard for us to meet, so I wanted a photo, that's what I thought.
Jake:你要多给几张才给查GPT
Jake: You need to give a few more to check GPT.
Alice:弱智吧
Alice: Are you dumb?
Jake:我得行
Jake: I can do it.
Jake:拍照挺
Jake: Taking photos is quite...
Jake:我觉得这张照片还行
Jake: I think this photo is alright.
Jake:多拍几张应该就BIOS
Jake: Take a few more shots, that should be BIOS.
Katrina: 不然他老坐我旁边
Katrina: Otherwise he always sits next to me.
Katrina: 我看不到他们的摄像头
Katrina: I can't see their cameras.
Nicous: 但是他的点已经不在于你们的行为了
Nicous: But his point isn't about your actions anymore.
Jake:没关系这个回头我们分析一下
Jake: No worries, we'll analyze it later.
Jake:我们找个人专门分析时段
Jake: We'll find someone to specifically analyze the timings.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright?
Jake:我们一共有15个摄像头跟8个第一视角
Jake: We have a total of 15 cameras and 8 first-person views.
Shure的女友:对那一天
Shure's GF: Yeah, that day.
Shure的女友:修跟我打视频电话嘛
Shure's GF: Shure's GF and I were on a video call, right?
刘婷:这是一只凤凰嗯
Liu Ting: This is a phoenix, hmm.
Shure的女友:然后视频电话呀
Shure's GF: And then a video call.
男嘉宾:哎哎说什么了你们
Male Guest: Hey, hey, what were you talking about?
Jake:什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Shure的女友:对然后然后然后你不是在那跟他讲
Shure's GF: Yeah, and then you were talking to him, right?
Shure的女友:就是啊OK
Shure's GF: Like, OK.
Shure的女友:就是一个什么北欧的男生
Shure's GF: It was some Nordic guy.
Shure: 那那是另一个
Shure: No, that was another one.
Shure的女友:我知道是另一个
Shure's GF: I know it was another one.
Shure的女友:我现在知道了
Shure's GF: Now I know.
Shure的女友:然后当时我来的时候
Shure's GF: And then when I came.
Katrina: 我的耳朵是我是捂得高高的
Katrina: My ears were completely covered.
Jake:那确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina: 我感觉你耳朵这样
Katrina: I felt your ears like this.
Shure的女友:然后然后当时看到
Shure's GF: And then I saw.
Shure的女友:我以为是你把他约出来了
Shure's GF: I thought you had asked him out.
Shure的女友:因为那个不敢约
Shure's GF: Because he didn't dare to ask.
Nicous: 有胆小鬼
Nicous: There's a coward.
Shure的女友:奥然哈哈
Shure's GF: Oh really, haha.
Jake:为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure: 你约他一顿饭呢
Shure: You invited him to a meal?
Shure的女友:约出来了
Shure's GF: Yes, asked him out.
Shure的女友:然后你能不能别倒了喝两口
Shure's GF: And then can you not pour and drink a bit?
Shure: 能不能别倒了喝两口姐
Shure: Can you not pour and drink a bit, sis?
Jack: 哦靠 cp cp
Jack: Oh wow, CP, CP.
Katrina: 我当时真感觉
Katrina: At that moment, I really felt.
Nicous: 你越不能把这张照片发给他
Nicous: You better not send that photo to him.
Nicous: 你要把你们俩照片发给他
Nicous: You should send the photo of you two to him.
Jake:来瞧一瞧瞧一瞧
Jake: Come on, take a look, take a look.
Nicous: 你把第二张照片发给他他就赢麻了
Nicous: If you send the second photo to him, he'll totally win.
Shure的女友:什么结婚照
Shure's GF: What wedding photo?
Nicous: 你就给爽到了到
Nicous: You just enjoyed it
嘉宾:第二张照片发给这男的
Guest: The second photo was sent to that guy
嘉宾:他直接作壁纸了
Guest: He made it his wallpaper right away
男嘉宾:对他他他直接就就就
Male Guest: Yeah, he just...
男嘉宾:颅内高潮颅内高潮
Male Guest: Had a mental climax, mental climax
Shure的女友:我我真的感觉
Shure's GF: I really felt
Shure的女友:就是当时看到你们俩的状态
Shure's GF: When I saw you two
Shure的女友:我以为他是那个人
Shure's GF: I thought he was that person
Shure的女友:然后我说呃OK
Shure's GF: Then I said, uh OK
Shure的女友:可能这个人
Shure's GF: Maybe this person
Katrina: 可是我对他没有那种很主动的行为
Katrina: But I didn't act very proactively towards him
男嘉宾:来来来
Male Guest: Come on, come on
Katrina: 我都没跟他说什么话呀
Katrina: I didn't even talk to him much
Jake:内部数据
Jake: Internal data
Jack: 分析一下
女嘉宾:我觉得挺正常的
Katrina: 因为我觉得因为我觉得尴尬了
Jack: 不知道我们这属于这一段
Jack: 属于因号此类吧
男嘉宾:可能正常的就是这个图片组
Male Guest: Maybe the normal one is this picture group.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Sister: Whatever.
女嘉宾:平等的撞死所有人
Female Guest: Equality will crush everyone.
Shure的女友:就是在这几天就是享受就好了
Sister: Just enjoy these few days.
男嘉宾:这个系列
Male Guest: This series.
Jack: 这个这个主要得有系列
Jack: This, this mainly needs a series.
Shure的女友:无所谓
Sister: Whatever.
男嘉宾:我到时候可以用这个数据集多多来
Male Guest: I can use this dataset more often later.
Shure的女友:sorry
Sister: Sorry.
Jack: 多多多来一次
Jack: Let's do it more often.
Katrina: 居然是这样的
Katrina: It's actually like this.
Shure的女友:sorry
Sister: Sorry.
Katrina: 居然是这样子
Katrina: It's actually like this.
Shure的女友:邀请你
Sister: Inviting you.
男嘉宾:没有没有你谋生哦
Male Guest: No, no, you make a living.
Katrina: 确实北欧男不来
Katrina: Indeed, the Nordic men don't come.
Shure的女友:对就是你活动娱乐活动就是怎么讲
Sister: Yes, it's your activities, entertainment activities, how to say...
Katrina: 是北欧男不喜欢然后
Katrina: The Nordic men don't like it, and then...
Shure的女友:你这种
Sister: Your kind...
男嘉宾:没有没有特别多
Male Guest: No, not that many.
Shure的女友:我来我我来北京
Shure's GF: I came, I came to Beijing.
Jake:很多啦
Jake: A lot, actually.
男嘉宾:没有特别多
Male Guest: Not that many.
Jake:特别多是啥意思
Jake: What do you mean by "that many"?
Jake:你这小地方
Jake: In your small place...
Jake:比这强劲的
Jake: It's way better than this.
Jake:几张照片了
Jake: How many photos?
男嘉宾:还好
Male Guest: It's okay.
男嘉宾:数据
Male Guest: Data.
Jake:七八
Jake: Seven or eight.
男嘉宾:主要是
Male Guest: Mainly...
男嘉宾:是你们得看那个摄像头里面的啊啊
Male Guest: You guys need to check the camera, right?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
男嘉宾:因为因为因为只能邀
Male Guest: Because, because...
男嘉宾:因为因为只能邀你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: Because you only invited one person.
男嘉宾:你只邀请到了一个
Male Guest: You only invited one.
Shure的女友:yeah just one对
Shure's GF: Yeah, just one. Right.
男嘉宾:对你只邀请到一个这个是
Male Guest: Yes, you only invited one. This...
男嘉宾:你只邀请到一个
Male Guest: You only invited one.
男嘉宾:这个事情就很就很tricky
Male Guest: This is really tricky.
男嘉宾:邀请的人家
Male Guest: Inviting people...
男嘉宾:你邀请不是人家问的你
Male Guest: You invite, not them asking you.
Shure的女友:对是你是你问他
Shure's GF: Right, it's you asking them.
Shure的女友:就是可能对你来讲
Shure's GF: So maybe for you...
Shure的女友:你筛选的选项就是啊在北京我认识
Shure's GF: Your selection is like, oh, I know people in Beijing.
Shure的女友:还可以很熟
Shure's GF: It's quite familiar.
Shure的女友:然后我可以邀请人
Shure's GF: And I can invite people.
Shure的女友:对他来说就是
Shure's GF: For him, it's like...
Shure的女友:对他来说就是哦他邀请我
Shure's GF: For him, it's like, oh, he invited me.
Shure的女友:只有一个我要邀请人
Shure's GF: There's only one, I have to invite people.
Shure的女友:我邀请人家哇
Shure's GF: I invite people, wow.
Jack: 女孩子在国内的语境
Jack: In the context of girls in China...
Jack: 女孩子主动邀请这种选择
Jack: Girls actively inviting this choice...
Nicous: 而且那个男生他就是在
Nicous: And that guy, he's just...
Nicous: 他需要的是
Nicous: What he needs is...
Shure: 前所未有的数据集
Shure: An unprecedented dataset.
Katrina: 我北京我不待几天
Katrina: I'm not staying in Beijing for long.
Katrina: 然后别担心一起见
Katrina: So don't worry, let's meet.
女嘉宾:我在看他在割双眼皮的一个
Female Guest: I'm watching him get double eyelid surgery.
Katrina: 见个面就不担心
Katrina: Meeting up makes it less worrying.
Shure的女友:别担心掉人生了
Shure's GF: Don't worry about losing life experiences.
Jack: 他现在肯定已经在回去的路上想着
Jack: He's probably already thinking about it on his way back.
女嘉宾:这是他在试验双眼皮
Female Guest: He's experimenting with double eyelids.
男嘉宾:到时候回武汉的时候
Male Guest: When he returns to Wuhan...
Jake:他有时候是
Jake: Sometimes he's like that.
男嘉宾:我一般去北京西站送
Male Guest: I usually drop people off at Beijing West Station.
女嘉宾:但是我看他这个封面区别还是蛮大的
Female Guest: But I see a big difference in this cover.
Jake: 点
Jake: Point.
男嘉宾:你也是这样的必是这样的
Male Guest: You are like this too, must be like this.
Jake: 点
Jake: Point.
Nicous: 我也在规划五一去武汉
Nicous: I'm also planning to go to Wuhan during May Day.
Nicous: 就是在纠结
Nicous: Just debating...
Katrina: 他也邀请过我
Katrina: He invited me too.
Shure的女友:6666 stop
Shure's GF: 6666 stop.
Katrina: 一起去玩
Katrina: To hang out together.
Jack: 卧槽一起出去玩你还要
Jack: Damn, to hang out together and you still...
Katrina: 但是我当然是
Katrina: But of course I...
Katrina: 到时候再说
Katrina: We'll talk about it later.
Nicous: 不是一起出去玩
Nicous: Not hanging out together.
Nicous: 就是很明显很难邀请的
Nicous: It's just clearly hard to invite.
Jake:这很难邀请的
Jake: It's really hard to invite.
男嘉宾:这这决对是他纠节了很久
Male Guest: He's been struggling with this for a long time.
Jake:很难出口的邀请来
Jake: It's hard to extend such an invitation.
男嘉宾:而且得并没有得到一个你直接否定的
Male Guest: And he didn't get a direct rejection from you.
Jack: 怎么说呢
Jack: How should I put it...
Jack: 因为他要求你
Jack: Because he asked you.
女嘉宾:好牛啊
Female Guest: So cool.
Katrina: 因为我觉得拒绝很尴尬
Katrina: Because I think rejecting is awkward.
Katrina: 就是大家是很好的朋友
Katrina: We're really good friends.
Jack: 男女生朋友单独一点
Jack: Male and female friends alone...
Jack: 但感觉就是就是从那个他的视角
Jack: But it feels like, from his perspective...
Shure的女友:他可能从从女孩子视角来讲
Shure's GF: He might be seeing it from a girl's perspective.
Shure的女友:不要担心任何事情
Shure's GF: Don't worry about anything.
男嘉宾:一两次
Male Guest: Once or twice.
Jack: 你那只有单独吗
Jack: Are you really alone?
男嘉宾:就单独两个人去
Male Guest: Just the two of us going alone.
Jack: 你那是真是去一个地方吗
Jack: Are you really going to a place?
Shure的女友:女生也可以有啊
Shure's GF: Girls can have that too.
Jack: 还是当天内的这种
Jack: Or is it just for the day?
Shure的女友:吊就行了我喜欢
男嘉宾:嗯就当天玩
男嘉宾:就当天晚上
Jack: 当天那不是正常吗当天
Jack: 当天就有这么好说吗
男嘉宾:那你说的是哪种
Jack: 过夜啊对啊
Jack: 对呀
男嘉宾:过夜那可以那
Jack: 对呀当天
Jack: 那当然是正常了
Shure: 要不我们三个
Jack: 过夜吗
Jack: 这种局这种局
Jack: 你能过夜吗
男嘉宾:这局也行
Male Guest: Sure, this round too.
Shure的女友:就是咱俩现在分手
Shure: So we're breaking up now.
Katrina: 我们俩在一起
Katrina: We're together.
Jack: 哎呀你想想
Jack: Oh, think about it.
Jack: 邀请你去
Jack: Inviting you to
Jack: 一个别的地方
Jack: another place.
Jack: 还单独邀请你去别的地方旅行
Jack: And even invited you to travel somewhere else alone.
Jack: 就不是这么等于
Jack: That's not the same.
Jack: 还不是一天
Jack: Not even for a day.
Jack: 对吧哦
Jack: Right?
Nicous: 他是说要致贺呀对呀
Nicous: He said it’s to celebrate, right?
Jake:就预约了
Jake: Just made an appointment.
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Katrina: 但是我肯定不会跟他单独去啊
Katrina: But I definitely wouldn’t go with him alone.
Katrina: 那当时就是拒绝什么的
Katrina: So I just refused at that time.
Katrina: 因为不好接受啊
Katrina: Because it's hard to accept.
Katrina: 我说我当时跟他去他真提出来这个
Katrina: I said if I went with him and he actually suggested this...
Jake:invitation就这个invitation
Jake: Invitation, that invitation...
Jake:太BIOS
Jake: Too biased.
Nicous: 出去玩之前和你在一起
Nicous: Before going out to play, you were together.
Nicous: 对你既然都已经拒绝了
Nicous: Since you already refused...
Katrina: 不是我在想我的好处
Katrina: No, I was thinking about my advantage.
Katrina: 我就说而且我这
Katrina: And I said, also...
Jake:今天又邀请来了
Jake: Invited again today.
Jake:不一样了给你说
Jake: It’s different, I'm telling you.
Jake:那
Jake: So
Nicous: 今天 可以了
Nicous: Today is fine.
Nicous: 你这定位加的有点多
Nicous: You've added a bit too much to the location.
Jake:你眼镜呢
Jake: Where are your glasses?
Katrina: 我眼睛在充电
Katrina: My eyes are charging.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 刚刚一直在充充电宝
Katrina: I was charging my power bank.
Katrina: 但是它还是显示没电
Katrina: But it still shows no power.
Jake:什么眼镜
Jake: What glasses?
Jake:就是什么充电宝
Jake: I mean, what power bank?
Jake:就这种吗
Jake: Like this one?
Jake:行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Jake:没关系这边有足够的数据
Jake: No problem, we have enough data here.
女嘉宾:你想你想让我第一视角
Female Guest: Do you want me to take a first-person view?
Shure的女友:妈妈带娃是的
Shure's GF: It's like a mom taking care of a child.
Jake:是的希望他以后能用到这个数据集
Jake: Yes, I hope he can use this data set in the future.
男嘉宾:哎你你这个数据题研究一下
Male Guest: Hey, you should study this data problem.
Shure的女友:我有点想跟他加个微信
Shure's GF: I kind of want to add him on WeChat.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure的女友:所以你跟他加可不可以
Shure's GF: So can you add him?
男嘉宾:这段我们没事这段我们可以搞成
Male Guest: This part, we can make it work.
男嘉宾:这这段可以
Male Guest: This part is doable.
Shure: 摄摄摄影师
Shure: Photographer.
Jake:知道
Jake: Got it.
Shure: 我们加个微信
Shure: Let's add each other on WeChat.
Shure: 后期后期
Shure: Later, later.
Shure: 这个照片对
Shure: This photo, right.
Shure的女友:哎哎哎毕业照是不是想我拍
Shure's GF: Hey, hey, hey, you want me to take the graduation photo?
Shure: 一百三百几来着
Shure: How much was it, one hundred or three hundred?
Shure的女友:no
Shure's GF: No.
Shure: 哎呀稍等
Shure: Oh, wait a minute.
Shure: 真真
Shure: Really.
Shure的女友:给你打个折好吧
Shure's GF: I'll give you a discount, alright?
女嘉宾:妈呀他大二才能看
Female Guest: He can only see it when he's in his sophomore year.
Nicous: 他不一定有时间过来
Nicous: He may not have time to come over.
Shure的女友:打折好吗
Shure's GF: A discount, okay?
Shure的女友:给你们打折
Shure's GF: I'll give you all a discount.
Jack: 在这都抱你
Jack: I'll hug you here.
Katrina: 他说要走了
Katrina: He said he has to leave.
女嘉宾:是人工智能哦专业叫人工智能哦
Female Guest: It's called artificial intelligence, the major is called artificial intelligence.
Katrina: 他说我们
Katrina: He said we...
Nicous: 不是真的抱了
Nicous: Didn't actually hug.
Katrina: 下一面什么时候再见就会抱你
Katrina: Next time we meet, we'll definitely hug.
Jack: 不是他怎么抱的
Jack: How did he hug?
Jack: 国内男女收
Jack: Domestic boys and girls...
Katrina: 因为他每次都这样
Katrina: Because he always does that.
男嘉宾:他每次都爽了
Male Guest: He enjoys it every time.
Nicous: 你你是会总结的
Nicous: You, you're good at summarizing.
男嘉宾:但但绝对不会放你过来
Male Guest: But, but he definitely won't let you come over.
Jake:不是 是什么同学
Jake: No, what classmate...
Jake:什么同学
Jake: What classmate?
Jake:什么关系
Jake: What relationship?
Katrina: 是保研的时候认识的一个网友
Katrina: It's an online friend I met during the research application period.
Katrina: 然后我们俩线下见面了然后后来就是
Katrina: Then we met offline and later on...
男嘉宾:是宝研认识的网友
Male Guest: An online friend met during the research application period.
Jack: 国内男女生朋友
Jack: Domestic boys and girls being friends...
Jake:保研认识
Jake: Met during research application...
Jake:什么意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jack: 线下见面
Jack: Met offline.
Jake:他是什么学阶
Jake: What was his academic level?
Katrina: 就是就在5月份的时候小红书认识
Katrina: It was around May, we met on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina: 然后就保研搭子
Katrina: Then became research buddies.
Katrina: 然后那个时候都发了一些链接
Katrina: And during that time, shared some links.
Katrina: 开营链接
Katrina: Camp links.
Katrina: 然后大家互通一些消息
Katrina: Then we exchanged some information.
Katrina: 然后呢后来9月份也没说什么
Katrina: Later in September, didn't say much.
Katrina: 然后11月份的时候
Katrina: Then in November...
Katrina: 他来武汉找我玩了一趟
Katrina: He came to Wuhan to visit me.
Katrina: 以后就开始每天发消息
Katrina: After that, we started messaging every day.
Jake:哦那也那确实那
Jake: Oh, so that, indeed, that...
Katrina: 然后就到现在都不职业到
Katrina: And now, it's been non-stop until now.
Jake:那这个时间线很标准啊
Jake: This timeline is very precise.
Jake:很很标准
Jake: Very, very precise.
Jack: 比较少因为我还是更爱拍朋友
Jack: It's rare because I still prefer to photograph friends.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
男嘉宾:你们俩聊天记录什么频率
Male Guest: How often do you two chat?
男嘉宾:看聊天记录日期嗯
Male Guest: Look at the chat history dates, hmm.
Jake:就走上正轨了
Jake: It's on track now.
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't talk much.
Jake:就是哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just... hahaha.
男嘉宾:没怎么说话
Male Guest: Didn't say much.
男嘉宾:但是天天在聊
Male Guest: But chatting every day.
Nicous: 你不回一下
Nicous: You don't reply?
Jake:来看一看
Jake: Let's take a look.
女嘉宾:看什么啊就是
Female Guest: Take a look at what?
Jake:啊就是哎这个错过的一个小影片
Jake: Oh, it's just a short film we missed.
Jack: 哈哈行了行了行了
Jack: Haha, alright, alright.
女嘉宾:对你没
Female Guest: Yeah, you didn't...
女嘉宾:你没看到那个
Female Guest: You didn't see that.
女嘉宾:嗯这个影片
Female Guest: Hmm, that film.
男嘉宾:建议这还说什么
Male Guest: What else is there to say?
男嘉宾:建议立刻按C1处理
Male Guest: I suggest handling it with C1 immediately.
男嘉宾:你看他老上海都是你
Male Guest: Look, it's all about you in old Shanghai.
Nicous: 知道他自我介绍的时候说什么吗
Nicous: Do you know what he said during his introduction?
女嘉宾:这这个词都是有意思的
Female Guest: These words are interesting.
女嘉宾:这个词词都是有啊
Female Guest: These words are all...
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:但是这个没有对应上画面
Jake: But it doesn't match the footage.
Jake:因为实在是剪不过来了
Jake: Because it's too hard to edit.
女嘉宾:对
Female Guest: Right.
Jake:就是就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:毕竟是
Jake: After all...
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:毕竟是presentation之前的一个小时嘛
Jake: It's just an hour before the presentation, you know.
Jake:对吧you know
Jake: Right, you know.
Jake:就是被抓了一下
Jake: Just got caught.
Katrina: 你说这种人会被抓到
Katrina: You think someone like that would get caught?
Nicous: 会哎呀
Nicous: They would, oh man.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
女嘉宾:写的挺好的
Female Guest: It's written quite well.
Lucia:对对是那个软是那个那个
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, that software, that...
Jake: GBD写的
Jake: GBD wrote it.
Lucia:啊 OK
Lucia: Ah, OK.
Jake:GPT写的
Jake: GPT wrote it.
Jake:然后搜搜AI谱的曲
Jake: And then AI composed the music.
男嘉宾:我就看你最近一直非常害怕
Male Guest: I just see you've been really scared lately.
Lucia:龙之队 哈哈哈
Lucia: Dragon team, hahaha.
男嘉宾:还发自拍哎呀
Male Guest: Even posting selfies, oh man.
Lucia:好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Jake:竟然没看出来
Jake: Didn't see that coming.
男嘉宾:我看出来了我一当当
Male Guest: I can tell, I'm the one.
男嘉宾:哦他没看着
Male Guest: Oh, he didn't see it.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:很多时候就是大家去找男生的话
Sister: Many times, when people look for guys...
Shure的女友:我一般找的都是工作上的
Sister: I usually look for work-related ones.
Lucia:我听见了 我说了谢谢
Lucia: I heard it, I said thank you.
Tasha:你有看过这段影像吗
Tasha: Have you seen this clip before?
Lucia:没呢
Lucia: No, not yet.
Lucia:对 啊谢谢
Lucia: Yeah, ah, thanks.
Lucia:我要我要确保一下
Lucia: I want to make sure...
Lucia:他没有把我表情包剪进去
Lucia: He didn't include my funny expressions.
Jake:放心你放心我有一点点审美虽然不多
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry, I have a bit of an aesthetic sense, even if not much.
Lucia:谢谢你有偶像包袱
Lucia: Thanks, you have some idol baggage.
Lucia:也不多但有一点谢谢
Lucia: Not much, but some, thanks.
Katrina: 他参加了蛮多夏令营
Katrina: He joined quite a few summer camps.
Shure的女友:所以加他去一些商太门
Sister: So he went to some business doors...
Lucia:好可爱呀哈哈
Lucia: So cute, haha.
Jake:有几个没剪进去因为实在是剪不进来
Jake: There were a few clips that couldn't be included because we just couldn't fit them in.
Jake:因为实在是没时间剪了
Jake: Because we really ran out of time to edit.
Jake: 开点了哈
Jake: It's starting, huh?
Lucia:哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia:哦这个居然留住了
Lucia: Oh, this actually stayed in.
Lucia:可以可以特别棒
Lucia: Okay, okay, that's great.
Jake:妙
Jake: Brilliant.
Lucia:特别好特别好
Lucia: Really good, really good.
Jake:妙 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant, brilliant.
Jake:特别好
Jake: Really good.
Jake:谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Lucia:我们的六面体老板
Lucia: Our hexagonal boss.
Lucia:哦 不是六面体老板
Lucia: Oh, not hexagonal boss.
Lucia:六面体
Lucia: Hexagonal.
Jake:我们的方形老板
Jake: Our square boss.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia:哎可以可以
Lucia: Hey, that's fine, that's fine.
Jake:对回去再做
Jake: Yeah, we'll do it again.
Jake:再再加几个
Jake: Add a few more.
Lucia:可可以的可以的
Lucia: Sure, sure, can do.
女嘉宾:他们还在八卦她
Female Guest: They're still gossiping about her.
Jake:对这个太容易八卦了
Jake: Yeah, it's just too easy to gossip about this.
Jake:竟然还在八卦
Jake: They're still gossiping.
Shure的女友:我不想我不想这这块被记录下来
Shure's GF: I don't want this to be recorded.
Lucia:他们怎么还没有八卦完
Lucia: Why are they still gossiping?
Alice:你想干什么
Alice: What do you want to do?
Jake:咋地 嗯
Jake: What's up? Hmm?
Tasha:下一盘是什么
Tasha: What's next?
Tasha:没有下一盘
Tasha: There's no next round.
Jake:没有下一趴就划水划到结束
Jake: If there's no next round, we'll just kill time till the end.
Jake:划到没电
Jake: Till the battery dies.
Lucia:划到没电啊
Lucia: Till the battery dies?
Jake:对就是各位加油把时间耗完
Jake: Yes, just hang in there and use up the time.
Lucia:好吧可是我充着充电宝他不会没电
Lucia: Okay, but with my power bank, it won't die.
Jake:就是没有sorry
Jake: There is no 'sorry'.
Jake:你怂了
Jake: You're chickening out.
Lucia:OK I SEE
Lucia: OK, I see.
Lucia:但是以他现在的状态
Lucia: But in its current state,
Lucia:他有可能插着充电宝也没电对吧
Lucia: it might die even with the power bank, right?
Jake:哦好的加油
Jake: Oh, alright, keep going.
Jake:充电宝加油
Jake: Go power bank!
Katrina: 大家都没有考虑这是什么啊
Katrina: Has anyone thought about what this is?
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:充电宝加油
Jake: Go power bank!
Jake:哈哈哈哈给我录
Jake: Hahaha, record this for me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:走要不戴
Jake: Let's go, or wear it.
Jake:要不戴上吧要不戴上吧
Jake: Wear it, come on, wear it.
Shure的女友:就不可能喜欢纯哥们
Shure's GF: It's impossible to like just bros.
男嘉宾:就是有没有那种能喜欢一点
Male Guest: Is there anyone who can like a bit more?
男嘉宾:坏怎么都是哥们
Male Guest: Why are they all bros?
男嘉宾:那不坏那不坏
Male Guest: That's not right, that's not right.
Shure的女友:没有一点关系
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter at all.
Katrina: 我要我要
Katrina: I want, I want.
Katrina: 喜欢的话我第一眼喜欢就是喜欢
Katrina: If I like someone, I like them at first sight.
Nicous: 为什么没带出
Nicous: Why didn't you bring it up?
男嘉宾:那你下次就告诉他你下次就告诉他
Male Guest: Then tell him next time, tell him next time.
男嘉宾:就说你就说
Male Guest: Just say it, just say it.
男嘉宾:我我我喜欢我喜欢的人第一喜欢就行
Male Guest: I, I, I like the person I like at first sight.
Jake:我草
Jake: Damn.
Alice:你是不是卖牙线棒来着
Alice: Are you the one selling floss picks?
Alice:你能给我顺一根吗
Alice: Can you get me one?
Alice:好像卡东西了
Alice: Seems like something's stuck.
刘婷:压线棒不是在你那个
Liu Ting: Isn't the line press in yours?
Lucia:网网网的问题
Lucia: It's a network issue.
Lucia:可能是你看他一直连接中
Lucia: Maybe, you see it's always connecting.
刘婷:朋友那吗
Liu Ting: Is it at a friend's place?
刘婷:忘了
Liu Ting: Forgot.
Lucia:就我
Lucia: It's just me.
Alice:哦啊 为什么是她 她拿走了
Alice: Oh, why her? She took it away.
Lucia:不知道是不是这个地方的问题
Lucia: Not sure if it's this place.
Lucia:还是怎么回事
Lucia: Or what's going on.
Lucia:反正我的网经常不行啊
Lucia: Anyway, my net often acts up.
Lucia:你那边那可能是我的我还没收到
Lucia: Maybe it's mine over there, I haven't received it yet.
Alice:你就不能给我留两根
Alice: Can't you save me a couple?
女嘉宾:但如果你要发的话得给我先p一下啊
Female Guest: But if you're gonna post it, you gotta edit it for me first.
Lucia:啊没问题
Lucia: Ah, no problem.
Lucia:你可以P好了发我
Lucia: You can edit it and send it to me.
Lucia:就发你P好的
Lucia: Just send the edited one.
Alice:咱俩就坐这
Alice: Let's just sit here.
Lucia:我特别的哎呀乘凉
Lucia: I'm really, oh, enjoying the cool.
Alice:哎呀哈哈哈
Alice: Oh, hahaha.
女嘉宾:好
Female Guest: Okay.
女嘉宾:那我可以把你现在的p一下
Female Guest: So can I just edit your current p?
Alice:咱俩退休以后也能这样坐着
Alice: We can just sit like this after we retire.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
女嘉宾:唉不是我p的也p不出
Female Guest: Oh, I can't edit it out.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:对一天一千五
Jake: Right, 1500 a day.
Lucia:没事放心就是就是
Lucia: It's fine, don't worry about it.
Lucia:我比如说跟别人合照的话
Lucia: If I take a photo with someone else,
Jake:可以去三亚
Jake: We can go to Sanya.
Lucia:就是朋友同一个情况下我才发
Lucia: I only post if we're with friends.
Alice:她家有
Alice: Her family has it.
Jake:哦真的啊
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake:那下回到他家拍
Jake: Then next time let's shoot at his place.
Lucia:所以就是我的懒主要体现在
Lucia: So my laziness mainly shows in...
Lucia:就是如果我朋友没P我就不P也不发了就
Lucia: If my friend doesn't edit, I won't edit or post it either.
Jack: 有人会喜欢这种所谓的胶片风
Jack: Some people actually like that so-called film style.
刘婷:咱们这还有下一回
Liu Ting: Do we have a next time?
Jake:哈哈哈万一呢
Jake: Hahaha, what if?
女嘉宾:我就哈哈哈错过下次错过
Female Guest: Hahaha, I might miss it next time.
Jake:万一有下回
Jake: What if there is a next time?
Shure的女友:胶片感
Sister: Film vibe
Shure的女友:但是你拍胶片要爱的毕竟胶片
Sister: But you have to love shooting on film, after all, it's film.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Right, right, right.
女嘉宾:如果我去主动去q这个流程然后
Female Guest: If I take the initiative to follow this process and...
Lucia:如果我
Lucia: If I...
Alice:深藏不露哼
Alice: Hidden talents, huh.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Right, right, right.
Alice:有小别墅你不告诉我
Alice: You have a small villa and didn't tell me.
女嘉宾:没关系
Female Guest: It's okay.
Shure的女友:我们我们前几天去了趟河北
Sister: We went to Hebei a few days ago.
刘婷:没有他也是就是这种
Liu Ting: No, he's just like that.
Shure的女友:然后我带了一个一次性的胶片
Sister: And I brought a disposable film camera.
Jake:那就我呢
Jake: What about me?
Jake:在哪啊
Jake: Where?
Shure的女友:就整个胶片拍出来
Sister: Just shot the whole film.
Shure的女友:感觉除了被手指挡到的那部分
Sister: Except for the parts blocked by my finger.
Lucia:啥呀 啥呀
Lucia: What? What?
Jake: 她说她家
Jake: She said her house.
Alice:她家
Alice: Her house.
Jake: 她家也有类似这样的院子
Jake: Her house also has a similar yard.
Alice:他家有这个这样的小院子
Alice: His house has this kind of yard.
Shure的女友:所有照片都是原图指出的
Sister: All the photos are original, pointed out.
Alice:他不告诉我啊
Alice: He didn't tell me.
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:刘婷你天天的
Alice: Liu Ting, you always...
Jake:在哪在哪
Jake: Where, where?
刘婷:在昌平那边昌平
Liu Ting: In Changping, over in Changping.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake: 昌平
Jake: Changping.
Alice:昌平
Alice: Changping.
Jake: 噢
Jake: Oh.
Alice:那有大型超市吗
Alice: Is there a large supermarket there?
刘婷:嗯附近吗
Liu Ting: Hmm, nearby?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
刘婷:嗯得开车
Liu Ting: Hmm, you have to drive.
Alice:多多远的车
Alice: How far to drive?
Jake: 咱也开车
Jake: Let's drive too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia:哎哎
Lucia: Hey, hey.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia:怎么突然断电了
Lucia: Why did the power suddenly go out?
女嘉宾:9点半
Female guest: 9:30.
Jake:他 他真讲究
Jake: He's really particular.
Jake:九点半
Jake: 9:30.
Lucia:才九点半哎
Lucia: It's only 9:30.
Lucia:好过份 至少也要十一点断电吧
Lucia: That's too much. At least cut the power at 11.
Alice:你在瞎录啥呢
Alice: What are you randomly filming?
女嘉宾:可是我发现啊
Female guest: But I found out...
女嘉宾:就是这个
Female guest: It's just that...
女嘉宾:其实你昌平在哪边
Female guest: Actually, where is Changping?
刘婷:其实你你就是拍你拍视频
Liu Ting: Actually, you're just filming videos.
Lucia:昌平在哪边
Lucia: Where is Changping?
刘婷:然后之后截图
Liu Ting: Then take a screenshot.
刘婷:他会比原来的色彩更还原一点
Liu Ting: It will restore the colors better than before.
Katrina: 你在瞎录啥呢
Katrina: What are you randomly filming?
Lucia:顺利是那边 昌平市昌平是市
Lucia: Shunyi is over there. Changping is a city.
Alice:那你亮灯的时候不拍
Alice: Why don't you film when the lights are on?
Alice:你这一灯一灭你在这拍啥
Alice: What are you filming with the lights off?
Lucia:昌平是西边是吧
Lucia: Changping is in the west, right?
刘婷:我刚摆上灯就灭了
Liu Ting: I just set up the lights and they went out.
Alice:我刚拍上灯就灭了
Alice: I just started filming and the lights went out.
女嘉宾:对西北边啊
Female guest: Yes, northwest side.
Lucia:啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice:你呢
Alice: What about you?
Lucia:我在北京的活动轨迹
Lucia: My activity range in Beijing...
Lucia:就只有从我们学校那边
Lucia: Is only from our school area...
刘婷:晚上像两只鬼啊
Liu Ting: At night, like two ghosts...
Lucia:就五道口那里到
Lucia: To Wudaokou and...
Alice:你说你是鬼就可以了 你带上我干嘛
Alice: You can say you're a ghost, don't drag me into it.
Lucia:对大概连线到天安门
Lucia: To Tiananmen in a straight line.
Lucia:就这一条线上
Lucia: Just on this line.
Alice:我请问呢
Alice: Excuse me?
Lucia:然后呢哈哈
Lucia: And then, haha.
Alice:你把你手机流量调调高呗
Alice: Why don't you increase your phone's data plan?
Lucia:也去但是去的很少
Lucia: I do, but very rarely.
刘婷:这个有用吗
Liu Ting: Is this useful?
Lucia:然后我实习的时候会去国贸这边
Lucia: So, during my internship, I would go to Guomao area.
Alice:嗯 有用啊
Alice: Yeah, it's useful.
Lucia:金台西照这里
Lucia: Around Jintai Xizhao area.
Shure: 没事我不录不录 唉
Shure: No worries, I'm not recording, not recording. Sigh.
Shure的女友:我们要讲些商业机密
Shure's GF: We need to discuss some business secrets.
Lucia:东边最远我大概就到这
Lucia: The furthest east I went was around here.
Lucia:然后除了对除了那阵就是打杂的时候
Lucia: Besides that, during the time when I was running errands.
刘婷:哎你别说你真别说
Liu Ting: Hey, don't say it, really don't say it.
Lucia:就是来黄泉城的那个
Lucia: When I went to Huangquancheng.
刘婷:哦
Liu Ting: Oh.
Alice:搞笑
Alice: Funny.
Lucia:就是拍片子打过杂嘛
Lucia: I used to run errands while filming.
Lucia:然后来过化妆这里
Lucia: Then came to the makeup area.
Lucia:就基本上咱们这了就来过一次
Lucia: Basically, I've only been here once.
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Hmm.
Lucia:然后其他的最远最远我就到国贸
Lucia: And the furthest I went was Guomao.
刘婷:算了
Liu Ting: Forget it.
刘婷:拍照拍的确实不咋地
Liu Ting: The photos taken really aren't great.
Jake: 没问题 我靠
Jake: No problem. Oh my.
Lucia:对我们进去了
Lucia: Yeah, we went in.
Lucia:但当时还没有正式营业
Lucia: But it wasn't officially open at the time.
Lucia:所以就没有在里面玩过 对
Lucia: So we didn't get to play inside. Yeah.
Lucia:然后
Lucia: And then...
Lucia:所以我对北京的很多地方
Lucia: So, I'm not very familiar with many places in Beijing.
Lucia:其实都不是很熟悉
Lucia: Because it's so big, I haven't been to many places.
Lucia:因为太大了就没去过
Lucia:对对对我现在是托了就是我
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, now it's because I'm...
Alice:你们是长租出去还是一天一租
Alice: Are you renting long-term or daily?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Lucia:上本科最后一年
Lucia: In my last year of undergraduate.
Jake: 没有 0% 这这这沟
Jake: No, 0%. This, this, this talk...
刘婷:长租啊
Liu Ting: Long-term rental.
Lucia:对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:你们沟就这样是吗
Jake: So you talk like this, huh?
刘婷:团队包的
Liu Ting: It's a team package.
Lucia:然后也不是很想去
Lucia: And I don't really want to go.
Lucia:就学校太大了就很麻烦
Lucia: The campus is too big, it's a hassle.
Shure的女友:交钱 给你拍了多少照片
Shure's GF: Pay up. How many photos did they take for you?
Lucia:因为我们要骑自行车才能出学校
Lucia: Because we have to ride bikes to leave the campus.
Katrina: 所以我就一直觉得大家也没有挑明
Katrina: So I always felt like no one ever made it clear.
Katrina: 我就觉得我是自作多情
Katrina: I just feel like I'm being over-sensitive.
Jake: 调监控
Jake: Adjust the surveillance.
男嘉宾:八 八个
Male Guest: Eight, eight cameras.
Jake:七七个 7台相机
Jake: Seven, seven cameras.
Jake:7台相机
Jake: Seven cameras.
男嘉宾:现在明明白白
Male Guest: Now it's clear.
Jake:回头那个网页专门给你整一份
Jake: I'll get you a specific webpage for that later.
Jake:那个拍位置的
Jake: For the positioning.
Jake: 对 那段啊
Jake: Yeah, that part.
Jake:啊剪出来
Jake: Yeah, cut it out.
Katrina: 当时跟那个北邮男的时候
Katrina: When I was with that guy from Beijing University of Posts and Telecommunications.
Katrina: 我就觉得好像是
Katrina: I felt like...
Katrina: 后期他又说什么不想谈恋爱什么
Katrina: Later he said he didn't want a relationship or something.
Katrina: 我以为就是我自作多情
Katrina: I thought it was just me being over-sensitive.
Nicous: 那是那北邮男
Nicous: That guy from Beijing University of Posts and Telecommunications is an idiot.
Katrina: 所以我对现在这个
Katrina: So about the current guy...
Nicous: 你不得反思哈哈哈
Nicous: You need to reflect, haha.
Jake:他怎么了
Jake: What's up with him?
Nicous: 他老让我反思
Nicous: He always makes me reflect.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 所以我就觉得这些男生的这些行为
Katrina: So I think these guys' behaviors...
Katrina: 可能就是他顺手分享的什么的
Katrina: They might just be casually sharing things.
Katrina: 然后就不要自己不要
Katrina: So we shouldn't...
Katrina: 觉得自己不要自作多情
Katrina: Feel like we're being over-sensitive.
Jake: 牛P
Jake: Awesome.
Katrina: 为什么要发啊
Katrina: Why send it?
男嘉宾:不是我给男生发
Male Guest: I didn't send it to a guy.
男嘉宾:对男生会发
Male Guest: Yeah, guys would send it.
男嘉宾:就每个人不一样
Male Guest: Everyone's different.
男嘉宾:就是每个人那个艺人的方向不一样
Male Guest: Each artist's direction is different.
男嘉宾:这不好拍
Male Guest: It's hard to shoot.
男嘉宾:挺好瞎处置
Male Guest: Just handle it casually.
男嘉宾:你就等他说吧
Male Guest: Just wait for him to say it.
男嘉宾:就按照现在
Male Guest: Just like now.
Nicous: 主要还是长太漂亮了
Nicous: Mainly because you're too pretty.
女嘉宾:但我最近就跟他们聊了
Female Guest: But recently I talked to them.
Nicous: 没事今天我给他搭回去啊
Nicous: No worries, I'll take him back today.
Katrina: 反正我是觉得就是来北京
Katrina: Anyway, I feel like coming to Beijing...
Nicous: 今天给他搭回去
Nicous: I'll take him back today.
Nicous: 回到100%的草药版
Nicous: Back to the 100% herbal version.
Jake:你这抗遗忘曲线挺挺挺棒的
Jake: Your anti-forgetting curve is pretty, pretty, pretty good.
Jake:我靠 越来越稳
Jake: Wow, getting more and more stable.
Jake:哈哈哈抗遗忘曲线你知道吧
Jake: Haha, you know about the anti-forgetting curve, right?
Shure: 刮刮吧
Shure: Scratch it.
Shure: 你看我能能刮多长就全转过去好不好
Shure: See if I can scratch it long enough to make it turn all the way around, okay?
Katrina: 带他玩吧带他玩吧
Katrina: Let him play, let him play.
Shure: 嗯回家还能让你花钱
Shure: Yeah, you can even spend money when you get home.
Jake:好忙啊
Jake: So busy.
Jake:这是赚多少钱
Jake: How much is this earning?
Jake:哭
Jake: Crying.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:乱写是吧
Jake: Just writing nonsense, right?
Tasha:还有这么多我怎么能不着急啊
Tasha:你相信吗
Tasha: Do you believe it?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Jake:愿意很多人愿意
Jake: Willing, many people are willing.
Tasha:你相信你对华侨文化的了解程度是
Tasha: Do you believe your understanding of overseas Chinese culture is...
Tasha:非常了解了解一般
Tasha: Very good, good, average,
Tasha:不了解还是非常不了解
Tasha: Don't understand, or completely don't understand?
Jake:等会等会
Jake: Wait, wait.
Jake:受访者对华侨文化不了解
Jake: The interviewees don't understand overseas Chinese culture.
Tasha:不了解对吧
Tasha: Don't understand, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:非常了解的有 34个
Tasha: There are 34 people who understand very well.
Tasha:了解的有47%
Tasha: And 47% understand.
Jake:他不应该画饼图吗
Jake: Shouldn't he make a pie chart?
Jake:为什么画垂线图
Jake: Why make a bar chart?
Tasha:不知道他呀
Tasha: I don't know about him.
Jake:傻逼对不起对不起对不起对不起
Jake: Idiot, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Tasha:他们两个字加起来
Tasha: Combine their two words,
Tasha:有80%的人都很了解华侨文化
Tasha: 80% of people are very familiar with overseas Chinese culture.
Tasha:这不是放屁吗
Tasha: Isn't that nonsense?
Jake:哪受众啊
Jake: Which audience?
Jake:受众群在哪
Jake: Where's the audience group?
Jake:他们学校
Jake: Their school.
Jake:华侨大学
Jake: Huaqiao University.
Alice:老板嘞
Alice: Boss.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah?
Alice:可以收工吗
Alice: Can we wrap up?
Jake:呃我行行 收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Uh, sure, sure, let's wrap up, wrap up.
Jake:收工 收工 收工吧
Jake: Let's wrap up, wrap up.
Jake:行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure的女友:even by shows
Shure: Even by shows...
Jake:好收工了收工了
Jake: Alright, we're done, we're done.
Jake:收工
Jake: Wrap it up.
Jake:不录了就就雨萱录一下吧
Jake: No more recording, let Yu Xuan record it.
Jake:别哈哈哈哈
Jake: Stop it, hahaha.
Jake:哈收工了收工了
Jake: Haha, we're done, we're done.
Jake:关机关机关机
Jake: Shut it down, shut it down.
Katrina: 因为我觉得
Katrina: Because I think...
Katrina: 因为我觉得人还是要相处的
Katrina: Because I think people need to interact.
Katrina: 觉得他是11月份的人
Katrina: I think he's a November person.
Katrina: 所以我就想了解
Katrina: So I want to understand.
Jake:好嘞关掉关掉关掉你关掉
Shure的女友:哎sorry
Shure's GF: Oh, sorry.
Nicous: 我我给你讲一个事情
Nicous: I, I have something to tell you.
Nicous: 我给你讲一个
Nicous: I need to tell you something.
Jake:complete
Jake: Complete.
Jake:哎 等会等会等会
Jake: Hey, wait a sec, wait a sec.
Shure: 我在数据集啊嘎嘎珍贵
Shure: I'm in the dataset, super valuable.
Jake:你嘎嘎牛逼啊
Jake: You're super awesome.
Shure: 这辈子
Shure: For life.
Shure: 没有另另外任何一个学术的数据集
Shure: there's no other academic dataset
Shure: 能有我这个数据
Shure: that can match my data.
Jake:哈哈当然绝对牛逼
Jake: Haha, of course, it's absolutely awesome.
Jake:对确实牛逼
Jake: Yeah, it's truly awesome.
Shure的女友:眼光来讲
Shure's GF: From a perspective,
Shure的女友:可能女孩喜欢男生只需要一瞬间
Shure's GF: a girl might like a guy in just a moment.
Shure的女友:会经过一个很漫长的思考
Shure's GF: But then she'll go through a long period of thinking.
Shure的女友:哦really because sorry
Shure's GF: Oh really because sorry,
因为因为因为因为因为
Shure's GF: because because because because because
Shure的女友:女生的情感会有一点点他自己的想法
Shure's GF: a girl's emotions might have a bit of her own thoughts.
Shure的女友:女生喜欢男生
Shure's GF: When a girl likes a guy,
Shure的女友:会因为他自的情感泛滥
Shure's GF: it might be because her emotions are overflowing.
Shure的女友:对传统眼光来讲
Shure's GF: From a traditional perspective,
Nicous: 我不懂啊
Nicous: I don't get it.
Shure的女友:因为他整个人情感泛滥
Shure's GF: because her emotions are overflowing.
Jake:重要数据
Jake: Important data.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure的女友:但是男生可能就是
Shure's GF: But guys might just be...
Nicous: 全球所有男生
Nicous: All guys in the world...
Nicous: 好好看
Nicous: So beautiful.
Jake:是吧好好看
Jake: Right? It's so beautiful.
Shure的女友:呃男宁女宁
Shure's GF: Uh, male and female.
Shure的女友:或者说母性体系父性体系的情况来讲
Shure's GF: Or speaking from a maternal and paternal system perspective.
Shure的女友:女生或男生的情况也可以培养很多
Shure's GF: Both girls and boys can be cultivated a lot.
Shure的女友:镜头喜不喜欢他无所谓
Shure's GF: Whether the camera likes him or not doesn't matter.
但是他喜欢的性质
But what he likes
Shure的女友:也是母亲的一种表现
Shure's GF: is also a manifestation of his mother.
男嘉宾:对了啊
Male guest: Exactly.
Jake:好好谢谢
Jake: Alright, thanks a lot.
Shure的女友:你可能没有跟他相处太久
Shure's GF: You probably haven't spent too much time with him.
Shure的女友:你的某一个
Shure's GF: One of your
Shure的女友:朋友圈或者你的某一个对
Shure's GF: friend circles or one of your, yes.
Shure的女友:呃感情的外放
Shure's GF: Uh, emotional expressions.
Shure的女友:会给他带一种哦特别浪漫
Shure's GF: Will bring him a sense of, oh, it's particularly romantic.
Shure的女友:然后或者特别他能get到那个点
Shure's GF: And maybe he can get that point.
Shure的女友:然后他就会突然觉得
Shure's GF: Then he will suddenly feel
Nicous: 男生想女人很简单
Nicous: Men thinking about women is very simple.
Nicous: 我个人觉得就是一瞬间嘛
Nicous: Personally, I think it's just a moment.
Shure的女友:就是就是一瞬间
Shure's GF: Exactly, just a moment.
Nicous: 这有什么的啊
Nicous: What's the big deal?
Katrina: 我再给你们讲
Katrina: Let me tell you more.
Katrina: 当时9月份的时候
Katrina: Back in September,
Katrina: 我们俩聊天还是就是半个月聊天
Katrina: We were chatting for about half a month.
Katrina: 他问我他手上几个offer怎么选
Katrina: He asked me how to choose between several offers he had.
Katrina: 然后我就跟他分享了
Katrina: So I shared my thoughts with him.
Katrina: 然后呢搞完研以后就摆了一阵子
Katrina: Then after he finished his research, there was a lull.
Katrina: 那个时候我已经参加很多活动了
Katrina: By then, I had already participated in many activities.
Katrina: 我就说然后他又问我最近在干什么
Katrina: So I told him what I had been up to recently.
Katrina: 他又觉得很空虚很无聊
Katrina: He felt empty and bored again.
Katrina: 然后当时还是朋友这种聊天嘛对吧
Katrina: At that time, we were still chatting as friends, right?
Katrina: 然后我就跟他说你可以去干什么
Katrina: So I told him, you can do this or that.
Katrina: 干什么干什么的
Katrina: Do this or that.
Katrina: 然后我说
Katrina: Then I said,
Katrina: 你可以
Katrina: You can
Katrina: 就是充分利用你这段gas的时间
Katrina: fully utilize this period of time.
Katrina: 然后
Katrina: And then
Nicous: 那我跟你说
Nicous: Let me tell you.
Katrina: 然后他给我写了一封信
Katrina: He wrote me a letter.
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh my god
Nicous: 这个男生就觉得你是一个非常的勾人
Nicous: This guy thinks you're super attractive
Nicous: 他就爱上了
Nicous: He just fell for you
Nicous: 可以吧
Nicous: Is that okay?
男嘉宾:乱七八糟的镜头
Male Guest: Random shots
Jake:每天8点叫人起床
Jake: Waking people up at 8 every day
Jake:贼牛逼
Jake: That's badass
Jake:值得让人哈哈哈哈
Jake: It's worth a good laugh
Jake:哎确实
Jake: Yeah, indeed
Nicous: 够了吗够了
Nicous: Is that enough? That's enough
Nicous: 还有什么呢
Nicous: Anything else?
Jake:够了
Jake: It's enough
Jake:除了吃他也不像海王
Jake: Other than eating, he doesn't seem like Aquaman
男嘉宾:谁啊
Male Guest: Who?
Nicous: 啊不像
Nicous: Ah, he doesn't
Jake:啊不像啊
Jake: Ah, he doesn't?
Jake:那那就是对啊那就没问题了
Jake: Then that's right, no problem at all
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:这个没问题这个没问题这个没问题
Jake: No problem, no problem at all
Jake:就是对 就是没问题
Jake: Exactly, no problem at all
Jake:对他当然可以喜欢你当然可以喜欢你
Jake: Sure, he can like you, of course he can like you
Nicous: 这不叫越界啊
Nicous: This isn't crossing the line
男嘉宾:如果他如果他觉得你越界
Male Guest: If he thinks you're crossing the line
男嘉宾:如果他觉得你越界
男嘉宾:是他的界限
Male Guest: That's his boundary
男嘉宾:你就是某一瞬间
Male Guest: You are just at some moment
Jake:卧槽8%的真牛逼
Jake: Wow, 8%, that's amazing
Katrina: 有任何暧昧的话
Katrina: If there's any ambiguity
Katrina: 之前跟他说我觉得不太想谈恋爱那种
Katrina: I told him before that I'm not really looking for a relationship
Nicous: 李欣达李欣达
Nicous: Li Xin Da, Li Xin Da
Nicous: 嗯嗯快点跟他认个错说挖醒他哈哈哈
Nicous: Yeah, hurry up and apologize to him, wake him up, haha
Katrina: 我去
Katrina: Oh man
Jack: 你们你们
Jack: You guys, you guys
Jack: 刚才情感召唤了
Jack: Just had an emotional call
Nicous: 情感上他老觉得他觉得自己会越界
Nicous: Emotionally, he always thinks he'll cross the line
Nicous: 真真不是我在想情感价都到哪了
Nicous: Really, it's not like I'm thinking where the emotional value is
Jack: 情感召唤到哪了
Jack: Where did the emotional call go?
Jack: 来来来不是
Jack: Come on, no
Katrina: 他喜欢我可以
Katrina: He likes me, that's fine
Shure的女友:stop stop
Shure's GF: Stop, stop.
Katrina: 但是我怕是因为我的一些言论让他
Katrina: But I'm afraid it's because of something I said.
Nicous: 停
Nicous: Stop.
Shure的女友:something i think can no sorry
Shure's GF: Something I think... no, sorry.
Katrina: 就是就是
Katrina: Just, just...
Shure的女友:停止你的所有脑补
Shure's GF: Stop all your overthinking.
Shure的女友:现在你其实其实他们都应该去回避一下
Shure's GF: Actually, they should all avoid this right now.
Jack: 我来说
Jack: I'll say something.
Nicous: 啊不回避啊
Nicous: Ah, no need to avoid it.
Nicous: 男生要学习
Nicous: Guys need to learn.
Shure的女友:就是你现在你的所有思想都应该是OK
Shure's GF: Basically, all your thoughts should be OK now.
Jake:啊走了走了
Jake: Alright, let's go, let's go.
Jake:没关系他录着了哈哈哈
Jake: It's okay, it's being recorded, haha.
Shure的女友:用用用用一句就是就是
Shure's GF: Just, just, just...
Shure的女友:就是就是东北人比较比较会讲话
Shure's GF: Northeastern people are good at talking.
Shure的女友:就是姐就是女王
Shure's GF: Like a queen.
Shure的女友:你现在就应该觉得哦OK
Shure's GF: You should feel like, oh, OK.
Nicous: 什么叫东北人会讲话
Nicous: What do you mean by Northeastern people are good at talking?
Shure的女友:就是所有人都应该围绕着我生活
Shure's GF: Everyone should revolve around your life.
Shure的女友:所有事情都应该围绕着我去发展
Shure's GF: Everything should revolve around you.
Shure的女友:就是你就是的top one
Shure's GF: You are the top one.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina: 这个我是就是一直的一个理念
Katrina: This has always been my belief.
Jake:咱要回避不用回避不用回避
Jake: We need to avoid it, no need to avoid it.
Katrina: 不会觉得
Katrina: I don't think...
Katrina: 因为这个男生会影响到我的人
Katrina: Because this guy would affect me.
Katrina: 我的性格啊什么什么的
Katrina: My personality or whatever.
Katrina: 但是
Katrina: But...
Shure的女友:OK
Shure's GF: OK.
Shure的女友:if you are the Queen
Shure's GF: If you are the Queen...
Katrina: 那我就
Katrina: Then I...
Katrina: 那我就可以给他随便发
Katrina: Then I can just send him...
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
那我就可以给他随便发
Katrina: Then I can just send him...
Shure的女友:如果你是那个女王所有人都该爱你啊
Shure's GF: If you are the Queen, everyone should love you.
Shure的女友:所有人都该爱你
Shure's GF: Everyone should love you.
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Shure: 就整个语言转换成英文
Shure: Just translate the whole conversation into English.
Nicous: 我没说你说的不对啊
Nicous: I'm not saying you're wrong.
Nicous: 就是他的点在于他刚刚跟我说
Nicous: It's just that his point is that he just told me...
Jake:OK再再喝点
Jake: OK, drink some more.
Nicous: 他说他做的事情有没有约见
Nicous: He said if what he did had an appointment.
Jake:再再喝点
Jake: Drink some more.
Katrina: 哈哈嗯我是怕我遇见导致他
Katrina: Haha, I'm just afraid I'll meet him and cause trouble.
Jake:哈哈会法语吗
Jake: Haha, do you speak French?
Nicous: 如果说真的有越界
Nicous: If he really crossed the line.
Nicous: 那是那个男的的问题啊
Nicous: Then it's that guy's problem.
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Shure: 现在是还会转换中文哦
Shure: Now she can switch to Chinese.
Shure的女友:啊sorry如果你跟所有的异性
Shure's GF: Ah, sorry, if you get along with all the opposite sex.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 不会转换中文OK
Shure: She can't switch to Chinese, OK.
Nicous: 都是这么相处的话
Nicous: If you always get along like this.
Shure: 那我每次我要跟他说中文
Shure: Then every time I have to speak Chinese with her.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Nicous: 你不需要你担心
Nicous: You don't need to worry.
Nicous: 你有没有越界
Nicous: About crossing the line.
Nicous: 就只是因为他对你所有的
Nicous: Just because he does everything for you.
Jake:你应该先学
Jake: You should learn first.
Jake:应该是骗局
Jake: It should be a scam.
Shure的女友:对你对他对你所有的动作
Shure's GF: Everything he does for you.
Shure的女友:还有一些另类想象就是他的问题
Shure's GF: And his alternative thoughts are his problems.
Shure的女友:对无所谓你喜不喜欢他
Shure's GF: It doesn't matter whether you like him.
Shure的女友:但他肯定是喜欢你
Shure's GF: But he definitely likes you.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Jake:yes
Jake: Yes.
Shure的女友:你不需要对这些东西进行一些内耗
Shure's GF: You don't need to waste energy on these things.
Shure的女友:就是你做你自己就可以了
Shure's GF: Just be yourself.
Shure的女友:你不要其实无所谓了
Shure's GF: You don't actually need to care.
男嘉宾:你不要听别人的
Male Guest: Don't listen to others.
Shure的女友:你如果喜欢他OK
Shure's GF: If you like him, OK.
Shure的女友:我采耳
Shure's GF: I pick my ears.
Katrina: 主要是我一直不知道他喜欢我
Katrina: Mainly, I never knew he liked me.
Shure的女友:我觉得喜欢他
Shure's GF: I think he likes you.
Katrina: 我知道今天给我说的这
Katrina: I know what he told me today.
Jake:now you know
Jake: Now you know.
Nicous: 你喜欢他非常好
Nicous: If you like him, that's great.
Nicous: 你不喜欢他
Nicous: If you don't like him.
Nicous: 你开心就可以了
Nicous: As long as you're happy, it's fine.
Nicous: 对啊他开不开心关你屁事
Nicous: Yeah, whether he's happy or not is none of your business.
Katrina: 哦哦哦
Katrina: Oh, oh, oh.
Nicous: 那我觉得
Nicous: Well, I think...
Katrina: 只是我现在非常震惊而已
Katrina: It's just that I'm really shocked right now.
Shure的女友:你可以忽略他所有的话
Shure: You can ignore everything he says.
Shure的女友:但是你可以在意他一句话
Shure: But you can pay attention to one thing he said.
Shure的女友:就是你开开心就可以了啊
Shure: Just be happy, that's all that matters.
Katrina: 那是那是
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 嗯但是但是我知道他喜欢我以后
Katrina: Mm, but now that I know he likes me...
Katrina: 我知道他喜欢我以后
Katrina: Now that I know he likes me...
Katrina: 我就感觉没法用哥们了那种
Katrina: I just feel like I can't treat him like a buddy anymore.
Nicous: 那是你的问题
Nicous: That's your problem.
Shure的女友:你这还是你当哥们都OK了
Shure: You can still be buddies, that's okay.
Katrina: 相处了
Katrina: Get along.
Katrina: 我就不想给他发那种东西了
Katrina: I just don't want to send him those kinds of things anymore.
Jake:那就不发了
Jake: Then don't send them.
Jake:对他都邀请来了
Jake: Yeah, he invited him anyway.
Jake:我们有gaste就很好
Jake: We have guests, that's great.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你都护体达成了是吧哈哈哈
Katrina: You even managed to protect him, right? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:我我我我和修硕大一谈过一个月还是两个月
Shure: I, I, I dated Shure for a month or two in freshman year.
Nicous: 1个月一个月
Nicous: One month, one month.
Shure的女友:一个月还是两个月吧
Shure: A month or two, right?
Shure的女友:你知道多久
Shure: Do you know how long?
Shure: 线上的
Shure: Online.
Shure: 差不多啊
Shure: About that.
Shure的女友:OK反正就是
Shure: OK, anyway...
Shure的女友:反正就一两个月吧
Shure: Anyway, it was about one or two months.
Shure的女友:然后我们两个的就是一个专业嘛
Shure: And we were in the same major.
Shure的女友:我们两个辅导员
Shure: Our advisor...
Shure的女友:然后一直以为我们就是那种怂类群
Shure: Always thought we were just part of the loser group.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Shure的女友:灵魂伴侣
Shure: Soulmates.
Katrina: 我也觉得你俩是灵魂伴侣
Katrina: I also think you two are soulmates.
Katrina: 他当时跟我讲了以后
Katrina: When he told me...
Katrina: 我就觉得你俩是灵魂伴侣
Katrina: I felt you two were soulmates.
Shure的女友:对然后中间就是从从大一分手之后
Shure: Yeah, then between freshman year and senior year after we broke up...
Shure的女友:他也谈过
Shure: He dated...
Shure的女友:我也谈过
Shure: I dated...
Shure的女友:然后后来发现
Shure: Then later we realized...
Shure的女友:嗯OK到大四了
Shure: Mm, OK, by senior year...
Shure的女友:然后哎
Shure's GF: And then, hey
Jack: 这个故事也很令人好奇啊
Jack: This story is quite intriguing.
Jack: 怎么就转回来了
Jack: How did it come back?
Shure的女友:所以说很复杂
Shure's GF: So, it's very complicated.
Shure的女友:哈哈那就讲很复杂
Shure's GF: Haha, so just say it's very complicated.
Shure的女友:讲讲讲然后现在又在一起了
Shure's GF: Keep talking, and now they're back together.
Jake:这能录对吧
Jake: Can we record this?
Jack: 这能录对吧
Jack: Can we record this?
这个能录这能录
Unidentified: Yes, we can record this.
Jake:这个能录好
Jake: Yes, we can record it, okay.
Jake:好记一下
Jake: Okay, make a note of it.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah.
Jack: 哈哈这个不能录
Jack: Haha, this can't be recorded.
Jack: 不能录就录我
Jack: If it can't be recorded, then record me.
Shure的女友:一会你开心就好
Shure's GF: As long as you're happy.
Jake:刚刚卡掉
Jake: It just froze.
Shure的女友:这就开始开心就好了
Shure's GF: Just start being happy now.
Shure的女友:你不管他们怎么样
Shure's GF: Don't worry about them.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure的女友:就是如果他们会对这些东西
Shure's GF: If they mind these things...
Jake:哎呦卧槽
Jake: Oh my God.
Shure的女友:有一些在意
Shure's GF: If they mind...
Shure的女友:那你就可以把他
Shure's GF: Then you can just...
Katrina: 因为就是有种不想惹麻烦的感觉
Katrina: Because it feels like I don't want to cause trouble.
Katrina: 如果他就是喜欢我就不想跟他说话了
Katrina: If he likes me, then I don't want to talk to him.
Shure的女友:你就可以把这些性归
Shure's GF: You can categorize this as...
Shure的女友:归类于他不尊重女性
Shure's GF: Categorize it as him not respecting women.
Shure的女友:就哈哈开心就好
Shure's GF: Just be happy.
Katrina: 为啥
Katrina: Why?
Katrina: 他喜欢我就可以
Katrina: If he likes me, that's okay.
Jake:可以你你你想你怎么想都行
Jake: You can think however you want.
Jake:我们你怎么想都行
Jake: We think you can think however you want.
Shure: 哈哈被夸了
Shure: Haha, got praised.
Katrina: 瞬间你全不是
Katrina: Suddenly, you're not...
Katrina: 他喜欢我可以
Katrina: He likes me, that's fine.
Katrina: 我确实应该被喜欢的
Katrina: I should be liked.
Shure的女友:你开心就好
Shure's GF: As long as you're happy.
Katrina: 嗯嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jack: 还是还是抓重点
Jack: Still, still focus on the main point.
Katrina: 我只是我只是刚开始一下没接
Katrina: I just, I just didn't catch it at first.
Katrina: 因为没有只是只是
Katrina: Because there's nothing, just, just...
Katrina: 我那个就有点震惊而已
Katrina: I was just a little shocked.
Katrina: 就是我觉得是好朋友
Katrina: I mean, I thought we were good friends.
Katrina: 我觉得
Katrina: I think...
Shure的女友:因为这个
Shure's GF: Because of this...
Katrina: 我们两个分手之后
Katrina: After we broke up...
Katrina: 呃怎么讲呢他去谈了个女生
Katrina: Uh, how do I say this, he started dating a girl...
Katrina: 我也去谈了个女生
Katrina: And I also started dating a girl.
Jack: 啊哈哈哈哈这个是可以录的
Jack: Ahahaha, can we record this?
Katrina: 厉害厉害
Katrina: Impressive, impressive.
Jack: 这个这个录上了
Jack: Let's record this.
Jake:这咋这咋
Jake: How, how...
Nicous: 没事我感觉输一局稳了
Nicous: It's fine, I feel like we're gonna lose this round for sure.
Katrina: 我
Katrina: I...
老板:这个这个要到example里边
Boss: This, this needs to go in the example.
Jake:谁敢B我
Jake: Who dares to 'B' me?
Jack: 你逼随便逼
Jack: You can 'B' however you want.
Jake:多多多多聊聊多聊聊
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Jack: 这个这个好好聊聊多聊聊多聊聊
Jack: This, this is good. Talk more, talk more.
Jake:多聊聊多聊聊
Jake: Talk more, talk more.
Jack: 啊啊其实这个是要做聊聊吗
Jack: Ah, ah, so we need to discuss this?
Jake:这个哈哈怎么这么聊啊
Jake: How do we talk about this, haha?
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Jake:怎么这么聊啊
Jake: How do we talk about this?
Jack: double呢还是怎么地呢
Jack: Double or what?
Jake:你怎么这么聊起来了
Jake: How did you start talking about this?
Katrina: 我也有很多异性朋友
Katrina: I also have many friends of the opposite sex.
Jack: 这个聊这个聊
Jack: Talk about this, talk about this.
Jake:这个聊法可能
Jake: Talking like this might...
Jake:就给我一句话我靠
Jake: Just give me one sentence, damn.
Jake:我靠哈哈
Jake: Damn, haha.
Katrina: 那是有意思
Katrina: That's interesting.
Katrina: 以后就变得很尴尬了
Katrina: It will become very awkward in the future.
Jake:就给一句
Jake: Just give one sentence.
Nicous: 对啊他的想法是他的
Nicous: Yeah, his thoughts are his own.
Nicous: 你的想法是你
Nicous: Your thoughts are yours.
Katrina: 不是今天我我只是震惊一下而已
Katrina: No, today I was just a bit shocked.
Jack: 我知道你的状态
Jack: I know your state.
Jack: 就是你特别你好
Jack: You are very good.
Jake:你好
Jake: You are good.
Tasha:我GDP崩了
Tasha: My GDP collapsed.
Katrina: 啊啊啊
Katrina: Ahhh!
Tasha:为什么
Tasha: Why?
Katrina: 因为我当时一直以为
Katrina: Because at that time, I always thought...
Jake:你GDP崩了
Jake: Your GDP collapsed.
Katrina: 就是每个人的相处方式不一样
Katrina: That everyone has a different way of interacting.
Tasha:就是回答不了我的问题了
Tasha: So you can't answer my question anymore.
Katrina: 可能就是我告诉你不要自作多情
Katrina: Maybe I was telling you not to overthink it.
Jake:来 来给你搞
Jake: Come on, let me fix it for you.
Jake:给你花钱
Jake: I'll spend money for you.
Katrina: 我一直觉得这样子
Katrina: I've always felt this way.
Jack: 国内就是
Jack: In our country...
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Katrina: 就是当时被北邮男搞了一下
Katrina: It was when I was messed with by a guy from Beiyou.
Katrina: 以后我觉得
Katrina: After that, I felt...
Jake:别冻着啊
Jake: Don't catch a cold.
Nicous: 或者说他就是喜欢MV
Nicous: Or maybe he just likes MV.
Nicous: 就是作为被喜欢的那一方是哎呦我靠
Nicous: As the one being liked, it's like, "Oh my god."
Jake:哎呦我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:这你妈
Jake: This is...
Nicous: 作为被喜欢的那一方其实是哎
Nicous: As the one being liked, actually it's like, "Hey..."
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 我会感觉到有点奇怪
Katrina: I feel a bit weird.
Katrina: 但是我总觉得是
Katrina: But I always think...
Katrina: 每个人相处方式不一样哎
Katrina: Everyone has different ways of interacting.
Nicous: 你觉得他喜欢你
Nicous: You think he likes you?
Nicous: 他肯定也是喜欢你
Nicous: He definitely likes you too.
Jake:我靠你怎么感觉出来了
Jake: How did you figure that out?
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:这这
Jake: This, this...
Katrina: 你说北邮的还是今天这个
Katrina: Are you talking about the Beiyou guy or this one today?
Jake:北邮的 你这个不是没感觉出来
Jake: The Beiyou guy. You didn't notice this one, did you?
Tasha:北邮的是哪个
Tasha: Which Beiyou guy?
Jake:你这个不是没感觉出来吗
Jake: You didn't notice this one, did you?
Katrina: 北邮这个
Katrina: The Beiyou guy.
Katrina: 当时10月份对我爆好你知道吗
Katrina: He was super nice to me in October, you know?
Katrina: 每一句就是他做的
Katrina: Everything he did...
Katrina: 比我前男友谈五年都做得好
Katrina: Was better than my ex-boyfriend of five years.
Katrina: 就我俩只出去玩过两次
Katrina: We only went out twice.
Katrina: 就是那种贴心程度包括情绪价值给的
Katrina: But the level of thoughtfulness and emotional value he gave...
Katrina: 然后后来12月的时候
Katrina: And then in December,
Katrina: 他就突然就是感觉干嘛来着
Katrina: He suddenly felt like, what was it...
Katrina: 不知道他说他忙工作去了你知道吗
Katrina: I don't know, he said he was busy with work, you know?
Katrina: 就感觉有落差感
Katrina: It felt like there was a sense of distance.
Nicous: 说不定工作遇到画家
Nicous: Maybe he met an artist at work.
Tasha:你看
Tasha: Look.
Jack: 就是觉得你一点反馈没有
Jack: It just felt like you weren't giving any feedback.
Katrina: 嗯我感觉可能也是我
Katrina: Yeah, I felt like maybe it was me too.
Katrina: 他可能在他的那个呃视角
Katrina: Maybe from his perspective...
Katrina: 他已经就表达的够明显
Katrina: He was already being clear enough.
Katrina: 但是我一直都没有
Katrina: But I never...
Katrina: 我我我后来觉得可能是这个原因
Katrina: I later thought that might be the reason.
Katrina: 因为因为北邮男是比较闷的那种性格
Katrina: Because the Beiyou guy has a more introverted personality.
Katrina: 然后我是后来就是有了落差以后
Katrina: And then later, after feeling the distance...
Katrina: 我才觉得
Katrina: I realized...
Katrina: 哎他之前怎么对我那么好
Katrina: Hey, he was so nice to me before.
Katrina: 就是我这人有点
Katrina: It's just that I'm a bit...
Katrina: 就是反射弧很长你知道吧
Katrina: You know, my reaction time is kind of slow.
Nicous: 他就觉得嗯
Nicous: He just felt, hmm.
Katrina: 然后跟北邮男这几个月没怎么联系以后
Katrina: And then after not keeping in touch with the Beiyou guy for a few months,
Jake:看看你的你
Jake: Look at your...
Jake:你你能上谷歌吗
Jake: Can you access Google?
Katrina: 没怎么联系了以后
Katrina: After not keeping in touch,
Jake:谷歌能上吗
Jake: Can you access Google?
Katrina: 这一次脱口秀看完以后
Katrina: After watching this stand-up show,
Katrina: 他回来又找我聊天了
Katrina: He came back and talked to me again.
Jake:哦脱口秀你们俩去的
Jake: Oh, you guys went to the stand-up show together?
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 因为当时是一起看的一起喜欢的富豪
Katrina: Because back then, we liked this comedian together.
Jack: OK那你怎么考虑呢
Jack: OK, so what are you going to do?
Katrina: 我又打算这个结束以后去找他聊一聊
Katrina: I plan to talk to him after this and clear things up, then go back to Wuhan.
Katrina: 就直接把话说清楚然后就回武汉
Katrina: Just say everything clearly and go back to Wuhan.
Katrina: 然后回武汉
Katrina: Then go back to Wuhan.
Jake:Google不开
Jake: Google isn't working.
Jake:Google
Jake: Google.
Jake:Google Google
Jake: Google, Google.
Katrina: 没有我做好了
Katrina: No, I'm prepared.
Katrina: 90%被枪毙得准备
Katrina: 90% prepared to be shot down.
翻了呀Tasha:
Tasha: Yes, I did.
Katrina: 没有就是表明心意吧
Katrina: No, it's just to express my feelings.
Jake:你没翻 没翻
Jake: You didn't turn it over. Didn't turn it over.
Katrina: 包括他当时就搞的我有点内耗
Katrina: Including the fact that he made me feel internally conflicted.
Katrina: 他突然一下那样子有点像断崖式暧昧
Katrina: He suddenly acted in a way that was kind of like abrupt flirting.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我就觉得我要去问清楚你为啥要那样
Katrina: I just felt like I needed to ask him why he did that.
Jake:Google Goo
Jake: Google Goo
Katrina: 你当时发生什么事情
Katrina: What happened at that time?
Jake:你去Google搜一个吧
Jake: Go Google it.
Jake:你去Google搜一个
Jake:随便搜个东西可以
Jake: Just search for something.
Katrina: 但是我也跟他说很多很多很多的话
Katrina: But I also said a lot, a lot, a lot to him.
Jack: 那就不知道了
Jack: Then I wouldn't know.
Tasha:这受不了了
Tasha: This is unbearable.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:怎么是个闭音啊
Jake: Why is it a mute sound?
Katrina: 你什么
Katrina: What?
Jake:上面有Google
Jake: There's Google above.
Jake: 你这没有网哦你必应都上不了哎
Tasha:哎这么笨啊
Tasha: Oh, how stupid.
Jake: 那你没得网
Jake: Then you don't have internet.
Katrina: 这我不太懂
Katrina: I don't really get it.
Jake: 你没得网
Jake: You don't have internet.
Jake: 你怎么知道加PPT
Jake: How do you know how to add PPT?
Katrina: 不太懂北邮男
Katrina: I don't really understand the guy from BUPT.
Katrina:  但是我跟北邮男当然是一个是相遇
Katrina: But of course, the guy from BUPT and I met by coincidence.
Jake: 什么叫我知道加PPT
Jake: What do you mean I know how to add PPT?
Katrina:  非常的奇妙你知道吧
Katrina: It was really amazing, you know?
Katrina:  就那么多学校偏偏我俩就参加了同
Katrina: Out of so many schools, we both just happened to join the same one.
Tasha:怎么办呢
Tasha: What to do?
Jake: 怎么办呢
Jake: What to do?
Katrina: 但是会带一些偶像剧的滤镜
Katrina: But it brings some idol drama filters.
Jack: 不要太在意过去的细节
Jack: Don't focus too much on the past details.
Jake: 怎么办呢
Jake: What to do?
Katrina:  啊我也是觉得就是现在看
Katrina: Ah, I also think that now...
Katrina:  所以我就打算这次就去表明一下心意
Katrina: So I plan to express my feelings this time.
Katrina:  然后就没了
Katrina: And then that's it.
Katrina:  要那要结果什么的肯定是
Katrina: If there's any result, it should be...
Katrina:  男方主动吧
Katrina: The guy taking the initiative.
Katrina:  要么拒绝要么在一起
Katrina: Either rejection or getting together.
Katrina:  难道还要我说我们要在一起吗
Katrina: Do I still need to say we should be together?
Katrina:  这样吗
Katrina: Like this?
Katrina:  多那个是吧
Katrina: That's too much, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh
Katrina:  我也不太懂
Katrina: I don't really get it either.
Katrina:  我感觉我就谈一段恋爱
Katrina: I feel like I'm just in a relationship.
Katrina:  所以这个男的对我我
Katrina: So this guy to me...
Katrina:  我也没怎么跟别人暧昧过
Katrina: I've never really been ambiguous with anyone else.
Katrina:  就不太懂这个
Katrina: So I don't really get it.
Jake:那他主动的
Jake: Was he the one who initiated it?
Jake: 那当然他讲呢
Jake: Of course if he initiated it, he should say something.
Jake: 他主动当然他讲
Jake: If he initiated it, of course he should say something.
Katrina:  嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  所以我觉得他当时有病啊
Katrina: So I think he was sick at that time.
Katrina:  所以我当然特讨厌北邮的
Katrina: So of course I really hate Beiyou.
Jake:那你被北邮
Jake: Then you were surrounded by Beiyou?
Jake: 被包围了那你
Jake: Surrounded by Beiyou, then you...
Katrina:  我被北邮包围了
Katrina: I was surrounded by Beiyou.
Jake:你要不你要不
Jake: Why don't you...
Jake: 明天你要不
Jake: Tomorrow, why don't you...
Jake: 后天去北邮参观一下
Jake: The day after tomorrow, go visit Beiyou.
Katrina:  我去过北邮
Katrina: I've been to Beiyou.
Katrina:  他带我进过两次北邮
Katrina: He took me there twice.
Jake:哦去过了是吧
Jake: Oh, you've been there, huh?
Katrina:  沙河跟海淀我都逛过了
Katrina: I've been to both Shahe and Haidian.
Katrina:  我现在我现在没有看
Katrina: Now, I don't see...
Katrina:  你们几个对女朋友都挺好
Katrina: You guys treat your girlfriends pretty well.
Katrina:  我觉得爱北邮的可能还行吧
Katrina: I think those who love Beiyou might be okay.
Jake: 就还行吧
Jake: They might be okay.
Jake: 就是这都是精英啊
Jake: They're all elites.
Jake: 这些都是
Jake: All of them.
Nicous: 卧槽他妈他妈四个四个
Nicous: Damn it, they caught four people and dragged me back, what for?
Nicous: 逮到四个人拉我回去干啥呀
Nicous: They caught four people, what do they want?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake: 网安哦网安哦
Jake: Cybersecurity, oh, Cybersecurity.
Jake: 网安院
Jake: The Cybersecurity institute.
Katrina: 我我不太那个男的想法
Katrina: I don't really understand what that guy is thinking.
Jake: 网络安全
Jake: Cybersecurity
Katrina: 所以我现在就是调整心态
Katrina: So now I'm just adjusting my mindset.
Katrina:  就是无所谓他对我什么态度
Katrina: Like, it doesn't matter what his attitude is towards me.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  我只是想去要一个答案而已
Katrina: I just want an answer, that's all.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  就去问一下
Katrina: Just go and ask.
Katrina:  然后我就回武汉
Katrina: Then I'll go back to Wuhan.
Jake: 你现在有网了
Jake: Do you have internet now?
Katrina: 如果我们俩在一起我就多待一天
Katrina: If we get together, I'll stay one more day.
Jake: 你有网了
Jake: You have internet now.
Katrina:  但是我已经做好了
Katrina: But I'm already prepared.
Jake:你就搞呗
Jake: Just do it.
Katrina:  90%被拒绝可能因为你
Katrina: 90% chance of rejection because of you.
Katrina:  你很明显
Katrina: It's obvious.
Katrina:  你翻以前的聊天记录跟现在就不一样
Katrina: When you look at our old chat records, it's different from now.
Katrina:  你懂吗
Katrina: You know what I mean?
Katrina: 就是会有落差
Katrina: There's a gap.
Katrina:  但是偶尔一次还行啊
Katrina: But once in a while is okay.
Katrina:  没有那那那就是很明显的
Katrina: But now it's very obvious.
Katrina:  之前秒回到现在就是一个小时回
Katrina: From instant replies to now taking an hour to reply.
Katrina:  一下午不回那种
Katrina: Sometimes not replying all afternoon.
Nicous: 我个人
Nicous: Personally,
Jake: 在哪里啊
Jake: Where is it?
Jake: 哎Google
Jake: Hey Google.
Tasha:Google Google也有怎么办
Tasha: Google, Google also has it, what do we do?
Katrina:  哎我当时也这么想的
Katrina: Hey, I thought the same thing.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Nicous: 就是一个消息一下午才回
Nicous: Like, a message takes all afternoon to get a reply.
Jake: Google
Jake: Google.
Nicous: 那不肯定在跟别人聊天
Nicous: He's definitely chatting with someone else.
Jake: Google
Jake: Google.
Tasha:什么什么时候才回
Tasha: When does he finally reply?
Nicous: 就是他发个消息
Nicous: Like he sends a message,
Nicous: 他奶奶一下午才回
Nicous: and it takes him all afternoon to reply.
Nicous: 一下午才回他在
Nicous: Takes him all afternoon to reply.
Jake: 他在干嘛
Jake: What's he doing?
Jake: 上班
Jake: Is he working?
Katrina:  不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Nicous: 哦他没上班
Nicous: Oh, he's not working.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Katrina:  没有没有
Katrina: No, no
Katrina:  他有自己的一个项目组在干嘛
Katrina: He has his own project team doing stuff
Nicous: 他有项目组
Nicous: He has a project team?
Nicous: 那也不能一个下午才回
Nicous: But he can't just come back in the afternoon
Katrina:  对啊而且那次断崖是很奇怪
Katrina: Yeah, and that sudden drop was really weird
Katrina:  就是之前两个月一直在每天聊天
Katrina: We used to chat every day for the past two months
Katrina:  然后12月的时候我从北京回去以后
Katrina: Then in December, after I got back from Beijing
Jake:唉 没有啊
Jake: Sigh, no way
Katrina:  就我俩见了一面
Katrina: We met up once
Katrina:  回去就不说话
Katrina: And after that, we stopped talking
Katrina:  因为他也不主动说话
Katrina: Because he wouldn't talk first
Katrina:  我感觉我老主动贴人家也没什么意思
Katrina: I felt like always being the one to initiate didn't make sense
Katrina:  然后我也不说话
Katrina: So I stopped talking too
Katrina:  然后就后来一两个月都不说话
Katrina: And then we didn't talk for a month or two
Jake: 另有新欢
Jake: Found someone new
Katrina:  是吧我觉得你再怎么忙
Katrina: Right? I think no matter how busy you are
Katrina:  然后我后来就问他
Katrina: So then I asked him
Katrina:  我他妈甚至我我
Katrina: I even, you know, I
Katrina:  我是一个非常直接的小女孩
Katrina: I'm a very straightforward girl
Katrina:  我直接问他
Katrina: I asked him directly
Katrina:  我说我在北京跟你吃饭相处这两天
Katrina: I said, during those two days we spent together in Beijing
Katrina:  我做了什么很让你很下头的事情吗
Katrina: Did I do something that really turned you off?
就是因为在我的视角只有那个人
Katrina: Because from my perspective
Katrina:  就是因为在我的视角
Katrina: From my perspective
Katrina:  只有那个人
Katrina: It was just him
Katrina:  突然就是我突然对他很下头
Katrina: Suddenly, I was really turned off by him
Katrina:  我才会就完全断了那种
Katrina: So I just completely cut it off
Nicous: 他怎么说的
Nicous: What did he say?
Katrina:  他说他这两天在忙那个项目
Katrina: He said he was busy with that project
Katrina:  通宵了两晚上
Katrina: Stayed up two nights
Katrina:  就是没有一点精神
Katrina: And was totally exhausted
Nicous: 晚上喝的也是一样的
Nicous: But he still drank at night
Katrina:  鬼知道啊
Katrina: Who knows
Nicous: 但是我啥时候问的
Nicous: But when did I ask?
Katrina:  但是我的想 12月12月十几号在北京
Katrina: But I thought, around December, mid-December in Beijing
Jake:12月
Jake: December
Katrina:  回去了以后一个星期他没让我说话
Katrina: After I got back, he didn't let me talk for a week
Katrina:  我就问他了
Katrina: So I asked him
Katrina:  我说啥意思
Katrina: I said, what's the deal?
Katrina:  然后他说他那个
Katrina: Then he said that
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Katrina:  嗯什么忙项目通宵了两天
Katrina: Uh, something about being busy with a project for two nights straight
Katrina:  是吧
Katrina: Right?
Katrina:  所以所以就少了少了
Katrina: So, so he missed out
Tasha:我只定了这一个
Tasha: I only booked this one
Tasha:节点倒是有很多有消息
Tasha: There are a lot of updates on the nodes
Jake: 有消息一天
Jake: Updates every day
一天Jake:
Jake: Every day
Tasha:充了一个月
Tasha: Recharged for a month
Tasha:一个月一个月充
Tasha: One month, one month recharge
Jake:换一换个新加坡的
Jake: Switch to one from Singapore
Jake: 换一换件
Jake: Switch to
Jake: 新加坡的
Jake: One from Singapore
Jake: 新加坡
Jake: Singapore
Jake: 我懂
Jake: I get it
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Jake: 嗯这样就行了
Jake: Yeah, that will work
Tasha:节点就不一样吗
Tasha: The nodes will be different, right?
Katrina:  为什么这个叫XBZ
Katrina: Why is this called XBZ?
Katrina:  为什么是什么时候出书啊
Katrina: When is it going to be published?
Jake: 确实差不多
Jake: It's about right
Tasha:哈哈换了有什么用
Tasha: Haha, what's the use of switching?
Katrina:  唉 我好像听过他歌是吧
Katrina: Ah, I think I've heard his song before, right?
Jake: 他  新加坡好
Jake: He, Singapore is good
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Jake:对哦
Jake: Yeah, oh
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 新加坡牛逼啊
Jake: Singapore is awesome
Jake: 然后给你充给你充给你充
Jake: Then recharge for you, recharge for you, recharge for you
Katrina:  这个
Katrina: This
Jake: 给他upgrade就帮助老板赚钱啊
Jake: Upgrade him and it'll help the boss make money
Jake: 啊这是以后给我们发工资
Jake: Ah, this will pay our salaries in the future
Katrina:  老师不是
Katrina: Teacher, no
Katrina:  提高他的效率
Katrina: Improve his efficiency
Katrina:  让他写论文更快
Katrina: Make him write papers faster
Jake:对对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes
Katrina:  加油
Katrina: Keep going
Katrina:  到时候你直接成我们这个工作室
Katrina: Then you can directly join our studio
Tasha:20美金一个月
Tasha: 20 dollars a month
2Tasha:0刀一个月啊
Tasha: $20 a month?
Jake: 20刀1个月
Jake: $20 for a month.
Tasha:你不是跟我说
Tasha: Didn't you tell me...
Jake:我这多少钱
Jake: How much is it here?
Katrina:  CHAT GPT 4吗
Katrina: Is it Chat GPT-4?
Katrina:  还是3.5
Katrina: Or 3.5?
Tasha:20刀一个月
Tasha: $20 a month.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Katrina: 那你可以用3.5也够了
Katrina: Then you can use 3.5, that's enough.
Katrina:  感觉 3.5淘宝买一个20块钱
Katrina: I think you can buy 3.5 on Taobao for 20 yuan.
Tasha:那不就一一万
Tasha: Isn't that just 10,000?
Tasha:1万6人民币一个月
Tasha: 16,000 RMB a month.
Jake: 呃确实
Jake: Uh, indeed.
Tasha:你之前怎么跟我说的
Tasha: What did you tell me before?
Jake: 我忘了
Jake: I forgot.
Katrina: 直接用他的号吧
Katrina: Just use his account.
Tasha:他跟我说他二三十人民币一个月
Tasha: He told me it was 20-30 RMB a month.
Jake: 我没说 新加坡新币
Jake: I didn't say that, it's Singapore dollars.
Jake: 新币新币差不多
Jake: Singapore dollars, about the same.
Jake: 但是好好的
Jake: But still...
Lucia:上次上次那个微微好像说过
Lucia: Last time, last time Weiwei mentioned it.
女嘉宾:为什么你们GPT4那么便宜
Female Guest: Why is your GPT-4 so cheap?
Lucia:对为什么
Lucia: Yes, why?
Katrina:  你们明天还来吗
Katrina: Are you coming tomorrow?
Tasha:他说他用他信用卡充的
Tasha: He said he used his credit card.
Tasha:然后我现在问他多少钱
Tasha: So now I'm asking him how much it costs.
Katrina: 啊别搞得像最后一面啊
Katrina: Ah, don't make it sound like it's the last time we'll see each other.
Tasha:他说价格不一样啊
Tasha: He said the price is different.
Lucia:你确定不是你之前记错了吗
Lucia: Are you sure you didn't remember it wrong?
Jake: 可能是记错
Jake: Maybe I did.
Tasha:他之前是多少钱来着
Tasha: How much was it before?
Tasha:三四十人民币
Tasha: 30-40 RMB.
Katrina:  明天不来吗
Katrina: Not coming tomorrow?
Lucia:对对对啊
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Nicous: 这么便宜
Nicous: So cheap.
Lucia:是这么说的
Lucia: That's what was said.
Lucia:但是我感觉他肯定错订单了
Lucia: But I feel like he definitely got the order wrong.
Katrina:  明天星期几啊
Katrina: What day is tomorrow?
Nicous: 这么便宜
Nicous: So cheap.
Katrina:  我已经过了
Katrina: I'm already past it.
Jake:可能是20刀吗
Jake: Could it be 20 bucks?
Katrina:  就是没有星期日
Katrina: There's no Sunday.
Jake:不可能吧
Jake: No way.
Katrina:  工作日和工作日
Katrina: Weekdays and weekdays.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha:明天早上什么时候走
Tasha: When are we leaving tomorrow morning?
Katrina:  问他后天是不是23号中午退房
Katrina: Ask him if we're checking out at noon on the 23rd.
Jake: 你说23号中午退房
Jake: You said checking out at noon on the 23rd?
Jake: 明天把这收拾收拾
Jake: Clean this up tomorrow.
Jake: 然后划划水
Jake: Then just relax a bit.
Jake: 明天没有什么任务
Jake: No tasks for tomorrow.
Jake: 划划水
Jake: Relax a bit.
Katrina:  明天那我睡到12点喽
Katrina: Then I'll sleep until noon tomorrow.
Jake: 可以没问题
Jake: Sure, no problem.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Lucia:太好了耶
Lucia: That's great!
Lucia:明天可以不用戴眼镜了
Lucia: I don't have to wear glasses tomorrow.
Jake: 明天戴眼镜戴眼镜
Jake: Wear glasses tomorrow, wear glasses.
Jake: 戴眼镜划水
Jake: Wear glasses and relax.
Jake: 加油划水
Jake: Relax well.
Katrina:  OK那我把明天把那风铃做了
Katrina: OK, then I'll make the wind chime tomorrow.
Jake: 对但是明天早上
Jake: Yes, but in the morning.
Jake: 明天早上吃午饭的时候
Jake: When you have lunch tomorrow morning.
Jake: 你们在外面吃午饭
Jake: You guys have lunch outside.
Jake: 然后我把屋子再扫一遍
Jake: Then I'll sweep the house again.
Jake: 你们都在啊
Jake: You all are here.
Jake: 你们把这个房就是房间给
Jake: You guys keep the room in its current nice state.
Jake: 就是还是现在的
Jake: It's still looking so good now.
Jake: 这么好看的样子哦
Jake: Sweep during the day and then disassemble it at night.
Jake: 白天扫晚上
Jake: Sweep during the day and at night.
Jake: 然后就可以拆了
Jake: Then it can be dismantled.
Jake: 呵呵呵对
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Jake: 给你充钱
Jake: I'll pay you.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Tasha:老板我两个杜卡七怎么办
Tasha: Boss, what about my two card readers?
Jake: 你两个读卡器我给你送回去呗
Jake: I'll send your two card readers back to you.
Jake: 你你现在
Jake: You, you now...
Jake: 就你最近要吗
Jake: Do you need them soon?
Jake: 你可以拿一个
Jake: You can take one.
Violet: 我拿一个吧
Violet: I'll take one.
Violet: 这两个是你的
Violet: These two are yours.
Jake:哦问下谢彬竹
Jake: Oh, ask Xie Binzhu.
Jake: 因为他
Jake: Because he...
Jake: 因为谢彬竹
Jake: Because Xie Binzhu...
Alice:老板明天还要录那个卧室吗
Alice: Boss, do we still need to record the bedroom tomorrow?
Jake:要录
Jake: Yes, we need to record.
Lucia:拆卧室是吗
Lucia: Are we dismantling the bedroom?
Jake: 我现在不拆啊
Jake: I'm not dismantling it now.
Lucia:不是我说明天要录拆卧室
Lucia: No, I mean recording the bedroom dismantling tomorrow.
Jake:明天要录拆卧室
Jake: Yes, recording the bedroom dismantling tomorrow.
Lucia:你是为了给大家建立一个逻辑联系
Lucia: You're trying to create a logical connection for everyone, right?
Lucia:是吧装了然后
Lucia: Right, and then...
Jake: 哎
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 懂了你哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Got it, haha.
Katrina:  啊他跟我说他去
Katrina: Ah, he told me he went...
Katrina:  他去不同的那
Katrina: He went to different...
Katrina:  每次带都不同的妹子
Katrina: Every time with different girls.
Jake:XBZ呢
Jake: Where's XBZ?
Jake: 哎呀傻叉
Jake: Oh, idiot.
Jake: 你们不开灯啊
Jake: Why don't you guys turn on the lights?
Jake: 你这么牛逼喜欢在深夜里工作
Jake: Are you so awesome that you prefer working in the dark?
Jake: 哎XBZ
Jake: Hey, XBZ.
Jake:在这了我靠
Jake: There you are, damn.
Jake: 二楼搞得不太好
Jake: The second floor setup isn't great.
Jake: 呃我要问他他觉得哪一个就是
Jake: Uh, I need to ask him which one he thinks is...
Jake: 你是有两个对吧
Jake: You have two, right?
Violet: 对呃 这有一个绿色
Violet: Yes, uh, there's a green one here.
Jake: OK然后我是想问他哪一个
Jake: OK, so I want to ask him which one...
Jake: 他想他想
Jake: He wants, he wants...
Jake: 好好行
Jake: Alright, okay.
Jake: XBZ XBZ
Jake: XBZ, XBZ.
Jake: 快快快快快快
Jake: Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Violet: 不是说我
Violet: Not saying me.
Violet: 是说哪一个
Violet: Which one...
Violet: 这个传输的速度快一点
Violet: Has a faster transmission speed?
Violet: 没有没有没有
Violet: No, no, no.
Violet: 就是这个
Violet: It's this one.
Violet: 哪个读法是传输速度快一点
Violet: Which one reads faster?
Nicous: 就这个
Nicous: This one.
Jake: 这个好还是那个好
Jake: Is this better or that one?
Violet: 绿色的方块
Violet: The green block.
Jake: 绿的
Jake: The green one.
Lucia:都行我可以
Lucia: Either is fine, I can do it.
Nicous: 窄的最好
Nicous: The narrow one is the best.
Violet: 嗯就是扁扁的
Violet: Yeah, the flat one.
Nicous: 对对对
Nicous: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 那这个带走好好好行
Jake: Then let's take this one. Okay, okay, good.
Violet: 你笔计本 是 是什么样子的
Violet: What's your notebook like?
Lucia:对我们其实有一个场记板
Lucia: Yeah, we actually have a clapperboard.
Nicous: 但是有人在用
Nicous: But someone is using it.
Jake: 第一天
Jake: The first day.
Nicous: 真的有人在打吗
Nicous: Is someone really using it?
Jake:第一天用一下
Jake: Use it on the first day.
Jake: 对第一天然后最后一天用一下
Jake: Yes, the first day and then the last day.
Jake: 嗯原来是希望每一场都用一下
Jake: Originally, I hoped to use it for every scene.
Jake: 结果吧就自然而然的就哈哈哈
Jake: But it just naturally... hahaha.
Lucia:导演你这个你知道
Lucia: Director, you know this.
Lucia:后期剪辑工作量就特别大
Lucia: The post-editing workload is really huge.
Jake: 呵呃
Jake: Haha.
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What's this?
Jake: 没有这个这些都是一直在录的
Jake: No, these have been recording all along.
Katrina: 找你的耳机呀
Katrina: Looking for your headphones?
Jake: 所以
Jake: So...
Katrina:  哈哈找笔记本
Katrina: Haha, looking for the notebook.
Lucia:是为了方便你
Lucia: It's for your convenience.
Lucia:之后但是他以为你
Lucia: Later, but he thought you...
Lucia:因为你其实其实做数字的
Lucia: Because you actually do the numbers.
Lucia:就如果说要剪
Lucia: So if you want to cut...
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia:为了方便你就知道是哪一块
Lucia: For your convenience, you know which part.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Jake: 是的
Jake: That's right.
Tasha:你不带的话你明天还会走
Tasha: If you don't bring it, you will leave again tomorrow.
Nicous: 后备箱请你今天怎么放
Nicous: Put it in the trunk today, how will you place it?
Jake: 我们每天对3次
Jake: We check it three times a day.
Nicous: 放后备箱
Nicous: Put it in the trunk.
Lucia:你是一个氛围氛围感道具
Lucia: You are a prop for the atmosphere.
Nicous: 还是后备箱
Nicous: Still the trunk.
Violet: 放后坐
Violet: Put it in the back seat.
Lucia:因为我不是导演
Lucia: Because I'm not the director.
Nicous: 上不了放不了
Nicous: I can't upload it.
Violet: 然后 对
Violet: Yeah, and then...
Katrina:  那你带后备箱哈哈哈
Katrina: Then you bring the trunk, haha.
Nicous: 明天再来
Nicous: Come back tomorrow.
Violet: 你明天或者后天再来
Violet: Come back tomorrow or the day after.
Jake: 啊明天再来
Jake: Ah, come back tomorrow.
Jake: 后天也可以再来
Jake: The day after is fine too.
Nicous: 我希望明天
Nicous: I hope tomorrow.
Nicous: 过两天再拿钱
Nicous: Get the money in a few days.
Nicous: 我靠
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 我怎么拿钱啊
Nicous: How do I get the money?
柳山Nicous:
Nicous:
Jake: 过两天
Jake: In a few days.
Violet: 我这有车
Violet: I've got a car here.
Jake: 都在上面
Jake: It's all up there.
Violet: 或者打车回去
Violet: Or take a cab back.
Violet: 那现在搞呗
Violet: Let's do it now.
Nicous: 笔记本不行啊
Nicous: The notebook doesn't work.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 你哪个笔记本呢
Jake: Which notebook?
Jake: 就一个笔记本
Jake: Just one notebook.
Jake: 你在我床上啊
Jake: Are you on my bed?
我们我们班那个学生节的时候
We're, during our student festival...
Jake: 你看看
Jake: Look.
Violet: 好像不是很平常
Violet: Doesn't seem very usual.
Violet: 就是拍我们班
Violet: Just filming our class...
Jake: 啊这里
Jake: Ah, here.
Violet: 班学生节一般都是就是舞台节目
Violet: Class student festival is usually stage programs.
Jake: 这叫ego life吧
Jake: This is called ego life, right?
Jake: 这个大家都有自己的生活
Jake: Everyone has their own life.
Lucia:家都有自己的生活
Lucia: Everyone has their own life.
Lucia:这个翻译
Lucia: This translation...
Nicous: 这么这么解释也好
Nicous: Explaining it this way is fine too.
Katrina:  slogan都有了我去
Katrina: There's even a slogan, geez.
Jake:好嘞明天见
Jake: Alright, see you tomorrow.
Jake: 已经看到自己的这宣传片了
Jake: Already saw our promo video.
Nicous: 你什么时候能关山啊
Nicous: When can you close the mountain?
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye bye.
Katrina:  滚没带
Katrina: Leave without it.
Katrina:  带你去好不好
Katrina: How about I take you there?
Katrina:  你在后面
Katrina: You stay in the back.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 我24
Katrina: I'm 24.
Katrina:  我23号约了他吃晚饭
Katrina: I have dinner plans with him on the 23rd.
Jake: 雨萱你看过这一段吗
Jake: Yuxuan, have you seen this part?
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn.
Nicous: 如果成了
Nicous: If it works out...
Jake: 来说说
Jake: Go on.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What are you talking about?
Nicous: 如果成了24号我们一起去动物园
Nicous: If it works out, on the 24th we'll go to the zoo together.
Katrina:  你咋知道
Katrina: How do you know?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Huh?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  你咋知道
Katrina:  我本来打算23号表白成功
Katrina: I planned to confess on the 23rd.
Jake: 确实本来就是
Jake: Yeah, that's the plan.
Katrina:  24号就跟他去的
Katrina: And then go out with him on the 24th.
Jake:事实上就是这样的
Jake: That's exactly how it is.
Lucia:主要主要
Lucia: Mainly, mainly.
Lucia:他们确实也没解释清楚具体想拍什么
Lucia: They really didn't explain clearly what they wanted to shoot.
Katrina:  动物园
Katrina: The zoo.
Katrina: 应该是就动物园野生有点远
Katrina: Maybe it’s just the zoo, the wild one is a bit far.
Lucia:但我后来发现
Lucia: But then I realized
Lucia:可能是因为导演自己确实不知道
Lucia: It might be because the director himself really didn't know.
Nicous: 我朋友准备20双租车险给我
Nicous: My friend is getting me 20 car rental deals.
Nicous: 要不要喊人
Nicous: Should we call people?
Nicous: 如果扯了我们一起去哈哈哈
Nicous: If we can get them, we can all go together, haha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真的假的
Katrina: Haha, seriously?
Katrina: 我在小红书上刷到了
Katrina: I saw it on Xiaohongshu.
Katrina:  我就住动物园附近
Katrina: I live near the zoo.